Sorry that you guys caught me off guard. I was just talking to Jason's wig maker, and he had said that they don't make the hair that Jason uses for the wig anymore because it's a synthetic thing and it has to do with it because they use a certain petroleum component to it, blah, blah, blah, blah. Anyway, the point is, if you see Jason on the street, just please say, hey, man, your natural hair looks great. It's an all-new smart list. Smart. Are you guys excited?
抱歉打扰了，你们把我吓了一跳。我刚刚在跟杰森的假发制作师聊天，他说他们不再制作杰森用来做假发的头发了，因为那是合成的，这跟里面用的某种石油成分有关，巴拉巴拉巴拉。总之，重点是，如果你在街上看到杰森，请跟他说，嘿，老兄，你的天然头发看起来真棒。这是一个全新的 SmartLess。太棒了。大家兴奋吗？
I'm excited. Do you know what I'm talking about? Yes. Are you talking about our, we're on the TV coming up? With the doc? We're going to be on TV. I told my whole family. Smartless on the road?
我很兴奋。你们知道我在说什么吗？知道。你是说我们，我们快要在电视上播出了吗？带着纪录片？我们要上电视了。我告诉我全家了。公路上的 SmartLess？
Smartless on the road. On Max. On Max. That, that new platform, yes. Yeah. Yes. Should we do what, should we see, should we watch it together? That's much fun.
公路上的 SmartLess。在 Max 上。在 Max 上。那个，那个新平台，对。对。是的。我们该怎么做，我们应该看看，我们应该一起看吗？那太有趣了。
That would be super fun. Oh, God, that's not a bad idea. I'm really excited. I'm excited for people to. See Will Fair. Sounds weird to say, well, yeah, I'm excited for people to see. Well, we have so many great guests. Yeah, so say some of the guests.
那会超级有趣。哦，天哪，这主意不错。我真的很兴奋。我为人们能看到……感到兴奋。看到威尔·费瑞尔。说“威尔”听起来有点怪，好吧，是的，我为人们能看到……感到兴奋。好吧，我们有这么多伟大的嘉宾。是的，说几个嘉宾。
We have Will Ferrell. Will starts it off, though, doesn't he? Will starts off, then we have Conan. Kevin Hart. Well, hang on, hang on, hang on. Then we have Letterman. Then we have AOC with special appearance by, can we mention that Bradley makes a special appearance.
我们有威尔·费瑞尔。不过是威尔开场的，对吧？威尔开场，然后我们有柯南。凯文·哈特。好吧，等等，等等，等等。然后我们有莱特曼。然后我们有 AOC，还有特别出演，我们可以提一下布莱德利有特别出演吗？
Bradley Cooper comes in, changes the light for us. And then we go to Chicago. We have Andy Richter and Jeff Tweety from Wilco. Mark Cuban. Mark Cuban. And then Maddie. Maddie Damon. Matt Damon, the Matt.
布莱德利·库珀进来了，帮我们换了灯。然后我们去芝加哥。我们有安迪·里奇特和来自威尔科乐队的杰夫·特维迪。马克·库班。马克·库班。然后是马蒂。马蒂·达蒙。马特·达蒙，那个马特。
Yeah, a turtle, quartal, worldel, perennial third place finisher, Matt Damon. And then one of the biggest guests of the entire tour is Tracy from Wisconsin. Tracy from Wisconsin comes on. Tracy. Sean's sister. My sister. Oh, Sean's sister makes an incredible appearance. Yeah.
对，一个乌龟，奎尔托，沃代尔，万年老三，马特·达蒙。然后整个巡演中最大的嘉宾之一是来自威斯康星州的特蕾西。来自威斯康星州的特蕾西登场了。特蕾西。肖恩的姐姐。我的姐姐。哦，肖恩的姐姐带来了一次惊艳的出演。对。
Oh, and doesn't your mother's right eye makes an appearance as well? And your mother's eye makes an appearance too. It's all true. By the way, it's all true, and you can see it. Get it? Don't get it. On Max, smartless, on the road. Check it out.
哦，你母亲的右眼也出场了对吧？你母亲的眼也出场了。都是真的。顺便说一句，这都是真的，你们能看到。懂了吗？不懂？在 Max 上，《公路上的 SmartLess》。去看看吧。
I'm glad you asked because I don't think they get it. And then, by the way, we come back to L.A., and then we end here with Kimmel. With Kimmel and Kevin Hart. I mean, we get to have, what a soft lander to come back and have our good buddy, Jimmy, Kimmel, and then Jan makes an appearance and, God, I mean. And then what's the final meal of the whole thing?
很高兴你问了，因为我觉得他们不懂。然后，顺便说一句，我们回到洛杉矶，最后以吉梅尔结束。还有吉梅尔和凯文·哈特。我的意思是，我们能有，回来能有我们的好哥们吉米·吉梅尔是多么轻松的着陆啊，然后简出场了，天哪，我的意思是。然后整个活动的最后一餐是什么？
Oh yeah, then we're over at Shawnee's house for some... Oh, we go to Shoney's right. Spaghetti Jos? Sloppy Jos. Sloppy Jos. I made sloppy Joe from scratch for you guys. Yeah. It's all on the dock.
哦，对了，然后我们去肖尼家吃点……哦，我们去肖尼餐厅了，对吧。斯帕盖蒂·乔？速食三明治。速食三明治。我为你们亲手做了速食三明治。对。全都在纪录片里。
It's all in the dock. Are we watching it at your house? Yeah, that's watching it. Let's watch it. We'll watch it on Max. It's kind of so fun. I think, I hope people like, who knows, but... We hope.
全都在纪录片里。我们在你家看吗？对，就在那看。我们看吧。我们在 Max 上看。这真的很有趣。我想，我希望人们会喜欢，谁知道呢，不过……我们希望如此。
It looks real good, too. Sam Jones did a great job directing it. It looks real handsome. It's black and white. I hope people like it's, it's why, it's May 23rd, right? May 23rd on Mac. Okay.
看起来真的很不错，山姆·琼斯导演得很棒。看起来真的很帅气。是黑白的。我希望人们会喜欢它，它，是 5 月 23 日对吧？5 月 23 日在 Max 上。好的。
I have a crazy story that happened. I told Will, I said I was going to save it to tell you today. You have some pre-show patter? Yeah. You know, Sean, and his... Go ahead, Sean. No, this is crazy. Sean, what have you prepared?
我有一个发生的疯狂故事。我告诉威尔，我说我要留到今天再告诉你。你有些演前闲聊？对。你知道，肖恩，还有他的……说吧，肖恩。不，这太疯狂了。肖恩，你准备了什么？
I've prepared this. Sean, by the way, not to interrupt it, speaking of prepared, there's somebody preparing something in the kitchen behind you. Yeah, Scott is going to make me some tea right now. Okay. Tea? Whoa, whoa, whoa. Are you fasting?
我准备了这个。肖恩，顺便说一句，打断一下，说到准备，你身后的厨房里有人在准备东西。对，斯科特现在要给我泡点茶。好的。茶？哇，哇，哇。你在禁食吗？
He's on Broadway, man. He's on Broadway. I'm on the Broadway. Oh, to keep your pipes nice and lubricated? Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Well, it is 1 o'clock there. What was for lunch today?
他在百老汇演呢，老兄。他在百老汇。我在百老汇。哦，为了保持你的嗓子润滑得好好的？嗯——嗯。嗯——嗯。好吧，那边已经 1 点了。今天午饭吃什么？
I just had a... I can't wait. I had a, what's it called? Like a Kaiser roll with egg and cheese and a little bacon. Apple juice. I had, what do they call it, like a foot-long sub? Kaiser Roll. Kaiser.
我刚吃了……我等不及了。我吃了，叫什么来着？就像凯撒卷，里面有鸡蛋、奶酪和一点培根。苹果汁。我吃了，他们叫什么来着，像一英尺长的潜艇堡？凯撒卷。凯撒。
Yeah. Where do you have to go to get that? Like a bread shop. Downstairs. Downstairs. No, Zabar's. Kaiser. Zabar's.
对。你得去哪儿买那个？像面包店。楼下。楼下。不，扎巴尔熟食店。凯撒。扎巴尔。
is a Jewish deli. We live right near it. And then there's a cafe, and they don't do bagels with egg. You'd think they would do bagels because they sell bagels in the store part, but not the cafe part, which is really crazy. You got to go full Kaiser.
是一家犹太熟食店。我们刚好住在它附近。然后有个咖啡馆，他们不做加鸡蛋的贝果。你会觉得他们会做贝果，因为他们在商店部分卖贝果，但咖啡馆部分不卖，这真的很疯狂。你得点全套凯撒。
All right. All right. So this is the story. This is crazy. This is going to blow your mind. I think it blew my mind. So the show takes place in 1958, backstage at the Tonight Show. Oscar Levant is the guest on the Tonight Show that night.
好吧。好吧。所以这就是那个故事。这太疯狂了。这会把你的脑子炸开。我觉得它把我的脑子炸开了。所以这个节目发生在 1958 年，《今夜秀》的后台。奥斯卡·勒凡特是那天晚上《今夜秀》的嘉宾。
The other guests, which we never see, we only reference a lot, is Jane Mansfield. Sure. Okay, who was, you know, this big star back in the 50s. Marilyn Monroe, Jane Mansfield, very similar. So Mariska Hargitte. You know Mariska Hargitay?
另一位我们从未见到、只是经常被提及的嘉宾是简·曼斯菲尔德。当然。好吧，你知道的，她是 50 年代的大明星。玛丽莲·梦露、简·曼斯菲尔德，非常相似。所以玛莉丝卡·哈吉泰。你知道玛莉丝卡·哈吉泰吗？
I do. Sure. Yeah, she's the star of the SVU thing. Oh, thanks, Scotty. Hey, Scottie. Thanks, Scott. She just made me tea. So she's the star of this show for like 20-some years, right?
我知道。当然。对，她是《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》的主演。哦，谢谢，斯科蒂。嘿，斯科蒂。谢谢，斯科特。她刚刚给我泡了茶。所以她是这个节目主演了二十多年的人，对吧？
So she's like, I'm outside of your theater. Come out. I'm like, oh, my God, I came out, gave her a hug, said hello. We took a photo. we're done and she go and somebody in the show whispers in my ear her mom is jane mansfield yeah i go wait a minute what yeah well mariska hargette's mom i go your mom is jane mansfield i go do you know that we reference your mom in this show over and over again did your mom know oscar levant she's like i don't i don't know um you know unfortunately she was very young when her mom died so then we go back and we say her bays
所以她就说，我在你剧院外面。出来吧。我说，哦，天哪，我出来了，给了她一个拥抱，打了个招呼。我们拍了张照。我们就结束了，然后她走了，剧里的某个人在我耳边低声说她妈妈是简·曼斯菲尔德。对，我说等一下，什么？对，玛莉丝卡·哈吉泰的妈妈，我说你妈妈是简·曼斯菲尔德，我说你知道我们在剧里一遍又一遍地提到你妈妈吗？你妈妈认识奥斯卡·勒凡特吗？她说我不知道，我不知道，嗯，你知道的，不幸的是她妈妈去世时她很年轻，所以我们回去说她的……
i go back in the theater and uh i forgot i text her i go by the way your mom made her Broadway debut in this theater that we're working in right now. Wow. No way. Isn't that crazy? Crazy, crazy. Yeah. So, um, did you at least offer her tickets to the show?
我回到剧院，然后……我忘了，我发短信给她，我说顺便说一句，你妈妈在这个我们现在工作的剧院里完成了她的百老汇首秀。哇。不会吧。这不是太疯狂了吗？太疯狂了，太疯狂了。对。所以，嗯，你至少问过她要不要来看演出吗？
No, she's got to pay for those. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you can give her access to the house. Yeah, I can get her. Her dad, her dad was, um, Mickey Hargatee, who was like a, uh, bodybuilder guy from Hungary. How do you know that? I know that.
不，她得自己买票。对。对。我的意思是，你可以给她通行证。对，我可以弄到。她爸爸，她爸爸是……米奇·哈吉泰，他是一个来自匈牙利的健美运动员。你怎么知道的？我知道。
I know that. Because he just Googled it. No, I didn't. I knew that before. And, um... Wait, why do you know, you know, vague Hungarian bodybuilders. Look, do you want to see my magazine collection or not?
我知道。因为他刚刚谷歌过了。不，我没有。我之前就知道。而且……等等，你为什么知道，你了解模糊的匈牙利健美运动员。听着，你想看我的杂志收藏还是不想？
No, I don't want to see your search history either. I do. I actually do. I read somebody in my search history the other day. There was such a bonkers all over the map. I go, here, you want to know what I've been searching up for the last 24 hours? And it was just the weirdest, stupidest stuff. I want to say just because I want to be, and I don't want to bring it down,
不，我也不想看你的搜索历史。我想。我真的想。我前几天在我的搜索历史里看了一下。简直是天马行空般疯狂。我说，给你，你想知道我过去 24 小时都在搜什么吗？结果全是最诡异、最蠢的东西。我想说，只是因为我想，我不想把气氛搞砸，
but I've got to be honest about where I'm at, if that's okay. Yes, yes. and then we can switch here. Is that okay? Yes, of course it is. It's very real. Do you want me to say? You want me to describe it?
但我必须诚实地面对我现在的状态，如果可以的话。可以，可以。然后我们可以在这里切换。这样可以吗？可以，当然可以。这非常真实。你想让我说吗？你想让我描述一下吗？
My oldest friend in the world, Jeremy, passed away. Oh. And I loved them so much. Oh, well, I'm so sorry. Yeah, you just found out yesterday, yeah? Yeah. And, um, fuck. Oh, God, I'm so sorry.
我世界上最好的朋友，杰里，去世了。哦。我太爱他了。哦，好吧，我太难过了。对，你昨天才刚知道，对吧？对。而且，操。哦，天哪，我太难过了。
And I just got to be honest about it because it's what's going on in my head. And, um, I, um, I just got to be honest about it because it's what's going on in my head. And, um, I, um. I just wanted to say that. I just, I love the guy so much. And it's so, Jason and I were talking today this morning. And it's funny, we always get surprised when people say, it's such a surprise, such a shock.
我必须对此诚实，因为这是我脑子里正在想的事。而且，我……我必须对此诚实，因为这就是我脑子里正在想的事。而且，我……我只想说这个。我只是，我太爱这家伙了。而且太……杰森和我今天早上还在谈论。有趣的是，每当人们说“这真是个意外，太震惊了”时，我们总是感到惊讶。
And we know that the deal is that everybody's going to die in something. We're here for five minutes. Yeah. You pass suddenly, well? You know, the last few weeks kind of came out of nowhere, certainly. And then he finally passed. And I'm happy he did. You know, obviously he was in a lot of pain.
我们知道的现实是每个人最终都会死。我们在这里呆五分钟。对。你突然去世了，好吧？你知道，过去几周确实有点来得很突然。然后他终于去世了。我很高兴他解脱了。你知道，很明显他承受了很大的痛苦。
And I'm just thinking about his family and all of them. And I've known them forever. And, you know, his daughter and his wife and his parents, whom my parents knew and our great-grandparents knew each other. Our families are intertwined for generations. And he was- So Jeremy was up in Toronto? He was in Toronto, yeah.
我只是在想他的家人和所有人。我认识他们很久了。你知道的，他的女儿、他的妻子和他的父母，我的父母认识他们，我们的曾祖父母也互相认识。我们的家族几代人交织在一起。他……所以杰里在多伦多？他在多伦多，对。
And he was one of the great guys. He's a, I always say he's a first ballot Hall of Famer. Just a great guy. you could always rely on them and and I miss them and you know you never um and I was just thinking this morning and I was taking the kids to school and it was just thinking like oh man hug the people you love yeah tell them as much as you can and if you're thinking about somebody call them let them know right just let them know you're thinking about them you love them how important they are to you um I love that and I just wanted to say that because it's all my mind and I love you guys so much
他是最伟大的人之一。他是，我总是说他是首轮入选名人堂的人。真的是个伟大的人。你总是可以依赖他，我真的很想念他，你知道你永远不会……我今天早上一直在想，我当时正带着孩子们去上学，脑子里就在想，噢，天哪，去拥抱你爱的人吧。对，尽可能多地告诉他们，如果你在想某个人，就打电话给他，让他知道，直接让他知道你在想他，你爱他，他对你有多重要。我喜欢这样，我只是想说出来，因为这全在我脑子里，我太爱你们了。
We love you. We love you too. Yeah. Yeah, it's, it is, you're right, it is this sort of like, you're always shocked that people die, but everyone here is going to. Everyone listening will. And it's like, it's a terrible thought. And we somehow have managed this little device inside our head and our heart to kind of put it in a little box and keep it away and deal with it at near the end of our life. We just kind of pretend it's not ever going to happen. But it does. And we just hope we use our time correctly. Yeah.
我们爱你。我们也爱你。对。对，就是这样，你是对的，就是这种感觉，你总是对别人的死感到震惊，但这里的每个人都会死。听节目的每个人也都会。这真是一个可怕的想法。而我们不知怎么地在脑海和心里设法搞出了这么一个小装置，把它放进一个小盒子里，藏起来，留到生命快结束时再去处理。我们只是假装它永远不会发生。但它确实会发生。我们只希望我们能正确地利用时间。对。
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. You know, I just did this, I just did this article, this interview. And Jay, you were so kind. I just read it. You said such nice things about me. And I appreciate it. I appreciate your generosity.
对。对，肯定的。你知道，我刚做了这个，我刚做了一篇文章，这个采访。杰伊，你太好了。我刚刚读了。你对我说了很多好话。我很感激。我很感激你的慷慨。
And I said, you know, if I can pull this thing off, great. If not, I'm still alive. Yeah. It's my quote. You know about the play? So you're feeling bullish about it. about the play. Yeah.
我说，你知道，如果我能成功演好这出戏，那就太好了。如果不能，我还活着。对。这是我的名言。你知道这出戏吗？所以你对它很有信心。关于这出戏。对。
It could suck, but at least I'm not dead. No, but the point is, to your point, well, is like, we're still here, we're here, we're here, right?
它可能会很烂，但至少我没死。不，但重点是，说到你的观点，威尔，就像，我们还在这里，我们在这里，我们在这里，对吧？
We're here. Nothing matters other than our health and our people we love and all that. And I just, yeah, I wanted to say that,
我们在这里。除了我们的健康、我们爱的人以及所有这些之外，其他什么都不重要。我只是，对，我想说这个，
just say, Jerry, we love you. And, and that's it. You know, thinking about you, buddy. And I also know that he was,
只是想说，杰里，我们爱你。就这样。想念你，老兄。我也知道他，
he was always so quick with a laugh and he loved to freaking laugh. This guy made me laugh. And so I don't know. He would, he'd be like, great, well, get to your guest. You have a nice opportunity to give him a nice goodbye this weekend with all of those people you're talking about. That's right. That's great.
他总是笑点很低，他超级喜欢笑。这家伙把我逗笑了。所以，我不知道。他会说，太好了，威尔，去应付你的嘉宾吧。这个周末你有一个很好的机会，可以跟你说的那些人一起好好跟他道个别。没错。那太棒了。
It'll be a wonderful thing for him to watch too. That's right. You know, I mean, that's one of the good things about after we go, right? We get to, like, it's a narcissist delight. You get to just pull up a chair and watch everybody saying, nice things about you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I love that.
对他来说，看这个也会是一件很棒的事。没错。你知道，我的意思是，这是我们离去后的好处之一，对吧？我们可以像，这简直是自恋狂的狂欢。你可以搬张椅子坐下来，看着每个人都在说你的好话。对，对，对。我喜欢这样。
At least that's my fantasy. I know. Well, it's one of your fantasies. Right. Just a big Jason session for a whole day. What are you eating? Right now? No. In that situation where you get... Oh. Where it doesn't matter anymore.
至少这是我的幻想。我知道。好吧，这是你的幻想之一。对。一整天都是大型杰森专场。你在吃什么？现在？没有。在那那种你得到……哦。那种不再重要的情况。
Just super salty puff-inducing things. Because, you know, you can be as puffy as you want upstairs. Sure, you can. Yeah. Turns out you can be as puffy as you want downstairs. But actually you lose water weight Almost instantaneously down there
只吃超级咸的、会让人浮肿的东西。因为，你知道的，你在楼上想肿多大就可以肿多大。当然，你可以。对。事实证明，你在楼下想肿多大也可以肿多大。但实际上你在地下几乎是瞬间就能减掉水分
Because you're always sweating Yeah Yeah it's hot as shit Oh where you're going Yeah you're going to get There's a lot of sweating going on That's a good point It's a constant schitz
因为你一直在出汗。对。对，热得像狗屎。哦，你要去的地方。对，你要去。那里有很多汗在流。这是一个好观点。简直是个源源不断的汗窟窿。
To switch gears Sure You know if we can As much as we can To somebody who's not puffy Really? No This gentleman keeps it very tight
转换一下话题。当然。你知道，如果我们能的话。尽可能地。聊聊一个不浮肿的人。真的吗？没有。这位绅士把自己保持得非常紧致。
In the best way I really A lucky son of it Yeah I know he He really is. He's got... This is a guy... You want to talk about
以最好的方式。我真的是。一个幸运的混蛋。对。我知道他。他真的是。他有……这是一个……你想谈论
First Ballet Hall of Fame, or this is the guy who's got it all. I mean, he's... When you got... When you got talent and good looks... Forget about it. When you got an easy way about you... Oh, boy.
首轮入选名人堂，或者这就是那个拥有一切的人。我的意思是，他是……当你拥有……当你拥有天赋和好外表时……别提了。当你拥有随和的性格时……哦，天哪。
For a freaking good guy. This guy's done it everything. He's been on the big screen. He's been on the little screen. He's been on the boards, you know, on stage, if you will. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This guy's from the other side of the pond.
真是个绝佳的好人。这家伙什么都做过了。他上过大银幕。他上过小荧幕。他上过董事会，你知道的，如果你愿意的话，上过舞台。对，对，对。这家伙来自大西洋彼岸。
Uh-oh. He's British. Yeah, well, he's actually Welsh. His first language is Welsh according to the internet. Huh. He's a guy who's done so much, and he's one of those guys who, like, every time you see him, you're like,
噢，不。他是英国人。好吧，实际上他是威尔士人。根据互联网的说法，他的第一语言是威尔士语。哈。他是一个做过如此多事情的人，他是那种你每次看到他都会觉得，
oh, I love this guy. Everything he does. This is the way I feel. You know, he was, for years he was on, you knew him from brothers and sisters, and then he was on the Americans forever. And the thing I love about him, maybe the most, is that he is partnered with
哦，我太爱这家伙了。他做的每一件事。这就是我的感觉。你知道，他曾多年出演……你从《兄弟姐妹》中认识他，然后他永远留在了《美国谍梦》里。而我最喜欢他的地方，也许是最重要的，是他搭档了
one of my all-time favorite people the delightful Kerry Russell. Guys, it's the incredibly talented Matthew Reese. Oh, Matthew. Yes, sir.
我所有时代最喜欢的人之一——令人愉快的凯瑞·拉塞尔。伙计们，他就是才华横溢的马修·里斯。哦，马修。是的，先生。
Is he gorgeous or what? Look at the stash. Look at him. There's no water in that face at all. No, not for years. We have a fifth guest today. He proved that the mustache was real. He pulled on it just to prove.
他是不是帅呆了？看看这小胡子。看看他。那张脸上一点水分也没有。没有，多年来都没有。我们今天有第五位嘉宾。他证明了小胡子是真的。他拽了拽它来证明。
No, no, I'm just checking the glue. Listener, he's got a 30-pound mustache on and it's looking strong. Are you playing a motorcycle cop? No, I'm doing the Tom Selig Biopin. You could. You could, welcome to Smartless Matthew Reeves. Thank you, thank you very much.
不，不，我只是在检查胶水。听众朋友们，他留着一把 30 磅重的小胡子，看起来很强劲。你在演摩托车交警吗？不，我在拍汤姆·塞立克的传记片。你可以的。你可以的，欢迎来到 SmartLess，马修·里斯。谢谢，非常感谢。
You know, that's the real terrifying moment, the reveal. I know. At the beginning, I was like, is he talking about Ian McKellen? Who are they expecting? What is this? This is going to go. It's Terran Edgerton, everyone. The real Welshman, who can say?
你知道，那才是真正可怕的时刻，揭晓谜底。我知道。一开始的时候，我在想，他在说伊恩·麦克莱恩吗？他们期待谁？这是什么？这要走向何方。大家好，这是塔伦·埃哲顿。真正的威尔士人，谁说得准呢？
Sure. Wow, it's so cool to meet you. I know. Very, very cool. Thank you very much for, for. having me on, Jen. This is a real pleasure. Matthew, I wish we don't know each other well enough.
当然。哇，很高兴见到你。我知道。非常，非常高兴。非常感谢你，感谢你。邀请我来，简。这真的是个荣幸。马修，我希望我们还不够了解彼此。
We've crossed paths a few times because, obviously, Carrie and I are old friends, and so we've met through Carrie. And she's such a delightful person, as you were well aware. And then she's like, I just, I love the idea. I'm like, you're as good as the people you hang out with. And the fact that you and Carrie together, I'm like, Matthew's a good guy.
我们有过几次交集，因为很明显，我和凯瑞是老朋友，所以我们是通过凯瑞认识的。正如你非常清楚的那样，她是一个令人愉快的人。然后她说，我就是，我喜欢这个主意。我说，物以类聚，人以群分。你和凯瑞在一起，我就觉得马修是个好人。
He's a great guy. No, I just, no. I took that idea. and then I latched myself onto KERRY so that those around us would think the same thing. By the way, that's smart. That's smart living. How long did you guys do that show together?
他是个大好人。不，我只是，不。我采纳了这个想法。然后我缠着凯瑞，好让周围的人也这么想。顺便说一句，这很聪明。这是聪明的生活方式。你们一起拍那个节目多久了？
Was it five, six? It was six years. It was meant to be five, and I think the poor showrunners had kind of arced it for five, and then FX went, you know what, let's do one more, and they went, oh, what?
是五年，六年？是六年。本来计划是五年，我觉得可怜的剧集运作人差不多把它规划成了五年，然后 FX 说，你知道吗，再拍一季吧，他们就说，哦，什么？
That's nice. We had the opposite on O'SRGE. That's a good sign on a show. We're talking, of course, about the Americans. Yeah. And Margot Martindale is a friend. And dear, dear Margottenale. Yeah.
那挺好。我们在《美国谍梦》上有相反的经历。这在节目中是个好兆头。当然，我们谈论的是《美国谍梦》。对。玛戈·马廷代尔是个朋友。亲爱的，亲爱的玛戈·马廷代尔。对。
They were both reunited on Cocaine Bear recently. Yes. So Margo, and you were in Cocaine Bear as well. Come on. I muscled my way in. Just looking out of the kids in Ireland and reading the script and that first opening scene, I said, I was like, who's playing that guy?
他们最近都在《可卡因熊》里重聚了。对。所以玛戈，你也在《可卡因熊》里。拜托。我硬挤进去的。只是在爱尔兰看着孩子们并读着剧本，看到那个开场镜头，我说，我在想，谁在演那个家伙？
The guy who bangs his head and falls out the plane? She's like, who? I don't know. And then I said, ask Elizabeth Banks. I said, ask Banks. was playing that part. So she texted, oh, we haven't cast it again. I said, tell, I'll do it.
那个撞到头并从飞机掉落的家伙？她就像，谁？我不知道。然后我说，问问伊丽莎白·班克斯。我说，问问班克斯谁在演那个角色。所以她发短信说，我们还没选定那个角色。我说，告诉，我来演。
Tell, no, just ask it if I can do it. And she very kindly said, yes, you can come in and fall out of an airplane. By the way, what an absolute treat? So you're directing a movie, and then you got a guy who's got like one scene, basically. And then you're like, Matthew Reese calls, and he's like, hey, can I just do this one scene? You're like, uh, are you kidding? Yeah, she smelled the desperation on me. I was like, can I please get out of the house.
告诉，不，只是问问我能不能演。她非常友好地回答说，可以，你可以来从飞机上掉下去。顺便说一句，这绝对是一种享受？所以你正在导演一部电影，然后你有一个基本上只有一场戏的家伙。然后你接到马修·里斯的电话，他说，嘿，我能只演这一场戏吗？你会想，呃，你在开玩笑吗？对，她闻到了我身上的绝望。我说，我求求你让我离开这个房子吧。
I can't do another zoo or aquarium. Sean is it true the rumor sorry that's how you and Scott met right didn't didn't you put in the search for cocaine bear no did I not hear that no I think technically it was cocaine cocaine cub wasn't it
我受够另一个动物园或水族馆了。肖恩，那个传言是真的吗？抱歉，那是你和斯科特相遇的方式，对吧？你当时没有在搜索栏里输入可卡因熊吗？不，难道我没听说过吗？不，我觉得严格来说那是可卡因小熊，对吧？
it was cocaine cup yeah it was the prequel that they haven't got it oh Scotty oh Scotty if he only knew so so you do cocaine and of course I want to get I don't want to just gloss over the delightful Margo Martin Dale, whom we all adore. Oh, yeah, she's the greatest.
那是可卡因小熊，对，那是他们还没拍的前传。哦，斯科蒂。哦，斯科蒂，如果他早知道的话……所以你搞可卡因，当然我想，我不想就这么一带而过我们都深爱的、令人愉快的玛戈·马廷代尔。哦，对，她是最棒的。
No one can swear like Margo Martindale. Oh. I mean, she should have a kind of course at NYU, like swearing for film and television, because no one can, no one can swear like her. And no one can get their ire up quicker and then get to swearing over, like, something that seems trivial. We did that show together, the Millers,
没人能像玛戈·马廷代尔那样骂脏话。哦。我的意思是，她应该在纽约大学开设一门课程，比如电影和电视中的粗口，因为没人能，没人能像她那样骂脏话。而且没有人能比她更快地被激怒，然后因为一件看起来微不足道的事情开始破口大骂。我们一起合作过那个节目，叫《米勒一家》，
and she'd be like, can you believe they just did this reroute? I got to fucking remember this fucking thing and they want to shoot this afternoon. you're like, Jesus, what? Yeah. She said of one very famous actor who's in our show, she went, can you fucking hear the way he breathes? I went, well, before then, I had, no, I happened, actually,
她会说，你敢相信他们刚刚改了路线吗？我他妈得记住这个狗屁东西，他们还想今天下午就拍。你会想，天哪，什么？对。她谈到我们剧里的一个非常著名的演员时说，你他妈能听到他呼吸的声音吗？我说，在那之前，我没有，其实我碰巧，
but I can hear it now. You brought it up. Oh, Jason, you love to work with her. Jason, you will so fall in love with Margo-Martindale. You won't be able to contain yourself. Guys, am I right? Yeah, gold. She's absolute gold.
但我现在能听到了。是你提出来的。哦，杰森，你太喜欢和她合作了。杰森，你会深深爱上玛戈·马廷代尔的。你根本控制不住自己。伙计们，我说的对吗？对，绝对是黄金。她绝对是金子般宝贵。
Now, tell me, Welsh is a... language? Is that what I heard you say, Will? Oh my God. First of all. Wait, so it's not English? Get ready for the letters. It's not English. It's much older than English. It's one of the oldest in Europe. So let's start there. So I just want to say, so Matthew, you are, it says that your first language was Welsh. Is that true? It is. It is. I grew up speaking Welsh, so the whole family
现在，告诉我，威尔士语是一种……语言吗？是我听你这么说的吗，威尔？天哪。首先。等等，所以这不是英语？准备好迎接批评信吧。这不是英语。它比英语古老得多。它是欧洲最古老的语言之一。所以我们从这里开始。所以我想说的是，马修，你的第一语言是威尔士语，这是真的吗？是的。是的。我从小就说威尔士语，所以整个家族
speak Welsh. But isn't Welsh just English with an accent? I don't understand. Yes, basically. What we do is trying to adopt such a harsh accent. No one really understands the English No, no, no, no, no. He's putting you on. So I've spent some time in Cardiff, which is where you're from, yeah, Matthew? It is. What were you doing there? I was filming there a few years ago, and I remember we had this. What were you driving? I had, I was going to say, the driver I had when I was working on that show, you know the guy.
都说威尔士语。但威尔士语不就是带口音的英语吗？我不明白。是的，基本上。我们做的是试图采用如此刺耳的口音。没有人真正理解英语……不，不，不，不，不。他在逗你玩呢。所以我在加的夫呆过一段时间，那是你长大的地方，对吧，马修？是的。你在那里做什么？几年前我在那里拍戏，我记得我们有这个。你开的是什么车？我有，我本来想说，我拍那个节目时分配的司机，你认识那个人。
Jerry Lockett? Oh, the Fet, the Locket Rocket. Oh, the Fet, Rocket, yeah, the famous Jerry Locket. What do you mean, driver? What are you talking about? You got a Rolls Royce. That's what I was trying to bait you to. Oh, no, no, no. Loan you a... Yeah, they loaned me a Bentley when I was in...
杰里·洛克特？哦，那个，洛克特火箭。哦，那个，火箭，对，著名的杰里·洛克特。你什么意思，司机？你在说什么？你有一辆劳斯莱斯。那就是我试图引诱你的地方。哦，不，不，不。借给你一辆……对，我在……的时候他们借给我一辆宾利。
When I was in London, I was drove around for a few weeks. I know. It's a long story. Wait, did you drive yourself in this Bentley? Yeah, I did. I did. I drove myself. Right side drive? Sure did. Oh, my God.
我在伦敦的时候，开了几个星期。我知道。说来话长。等等，你自己开这辆宾利吗？对，我开了。我开了。我自己开的。右舵驾驶？当然开了。哦，天哪。
And then I drove up to Ricky's to Jervis' house in London because I was going to have... Go to his house to have just a visit. Who are you? And I called him and I said, I'm outside and he came out and he saw me in this Bentley and go, where can I park this thing around here? And he was like, Jesus, fucking Christ. It wasn't mine.
然后我开到伦敦里奇·贾维斯的家里，因为我要去……去他家拜访一下。你到底是谁？我给他打电话说我在外面，他出来看到我开着这辆宾利，说我这车能停在这附近哪里？然后他就说，耶稣基督他妈的。那不是我的。
It was literally, I don't drive a Bentley. That was why I made a point. Anyway, so you're from Cardiff. We know Jerry Lockett. We've got Jerry out there. We know that he's listening. We love you, Jerry. So we know that you do.
那真的是，我才不买宾利呢。这就是我提出这一点的原因。总之，你是加的夫出身。我们认识杰里·洛克特。杰里就在那儿。我们知道他在听。我们爱你，杰里。所以我们知道你……
How are you? And I knew that you guys knew each other because he was always like, do you know Matthew Reese? And I was like, I do. I do a little bit because I know Kerry. He says, yeah, Matthew, Matthew's from here. And he's so proud of you. And all the Welsh, you're so proud of Matthew for what you've done.
你好吗？我知道你们互相认识，因为他总是说，你认识马修·里斯吗？我说我认识。我稍微认识一点，因为我认识凯瑞。他说，对，马修，马修就是这儿的人。他为你感到非常骄傲。所有的威尔士人，都为马修你所取得的成就感到骄傲。
I think there's, because there's only three, million of us, three and a half million. That's all of Canada, isn't it? What? What is the population of Canada now? 30, 30. Oh, okay. You missed it by a zero.
我想，因为我们只有三百万人口，三百万半。那是整个加拿大，对吧？什么？加拿大现在的人口是多少？三十，三十。哦，好吧。你差了一个零。
10%. Yeah. So anyone who's Welsh and has done anything, even if they haven't done anything, we're just inherently proud for a country the size of Connecticut. Two of them are named Bale and one of them is named Reese. Yes, that's it. So Christian Gareth and Bail and Matthew Reese. Well, there's also Hopkins.
10%。对。所以任何威尔士人，只要做出过什么成就，哪怕他们什么都没做，对于一个只有康涅狄格州大小的国家来说，我们天然地就会感到骄傲。其中两个人叫贝尔，一个人叫里斯。对，就是这样。所以克里斯蒂安、加雷斯、贝尔和马修·里斯。嗯，还有霍普金斯。
You also got Hopkins. Oh, yeah. You do. Yeah. And then Burton, obviously. There are a bunch of them. So wait, I don't know. I don't know anything about you, and I know you.
你还有霍普金斯。哦，对。确实有。然后显然还有伯顿。有一大堆呢。所以等等，我不知道。我对你一无所知，而我了解你。
I know you, I know you. So were you one of those people that grew up in the theater and stuff as a kid? And you're like, oh my God, if I can go to America, wow. We're going to get to that, John. That's exactly right. She's right in the middle of a story. He's telling the story. What story about a Rolls-Royce and a Bentley?
我了解你，我了解你。所以你小时候也是那种在剧院里长大的人吗？然后你会想，哦，天哪，如果我能去美国，哇。我们要谈到那个，约翰。完全正确。她正说到故事的中心。他在讲故事。什么关于劳斯莱斯和宾利的故事？
Speaking Welsh is his first language. Say something in Welsh. Landing the plane on that. Okay, sorry. Go ahead, Matthew. and... Sean, check your chat, please. So talk about, no, but growing up, speaking well,
说威尔士语是他的第一语言。用威尔士语说点什么。把飞机安全降落吧。好吧，抱歉。请继续，马修。而且……肖恩，请查看你的聊天记录。所以聊聊，不，但是从小就说威尔士语，
you guys spoke Welsh at home, yeah? We did, we did. And in Wales, there's a great, you know, there's a great reverence for, you know, performing arts, and there's a very, there's kind of an ancient tradition. It's pre-Christian, whereby everyone congregate, in the old days,
你们在家说威尔士语，对吧？我们说，我们说。在威尔士，人们对表演艺术有着极大的崇敬，并且有一种非常古老的传统。那是基督教之前的时期，过去每个人都会聚集在一起，
everyone would congregate, and then you would sing competitively or cite poetry or anything of that ilk, basically. And it's very modern these days, but twice a year, all the children of Wales will gather. And it's a competition now, but you're very much encouraged to get on stage and in some form, art form or another,
大家会聚集在一起，然后进行竞技歌唱、背诵诗歌或任何诸如此类的艺术形式，基本上就是这样。现在它非常现代，但一年两次，威尔士所有的孩子都会聚集在一起。现在这是一个比赛，但你非常被鼓励登上舞台，以某种艺术形式或其他形式，
and compete for your school or your county or whatever. Oh, wow. So, yeah, so from a very early age, you're kind of kicked onto a stage whether you want to. Really? Yeah, yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. All right, back to the show.
为你的学校或你的郡或者其他什么而竞争。哦，哇。所以，是的，所以从很小的时候起，不管你愿不愿意，你基本上就被踢上了一个舞台。真的吗？对，对。好了，广告时间。好的，回到节目。
So you grow up, you're speaking well, obviously you speak English as well. They speak both there. The signage and stuff in Wales is delightful. It's, you know, one in English and one in Welsh. And it's a, it's tough to read. It's a hotbed of contention, yeah. What's the distance between English and Welsh? I mean, I've absolutely no idea what it sounds like, what it looks like.
所以你长大了，你说威尔士语，显然你也说英语。那里两种语言都说。威尔士的路标和其他东西太令人愉快了。一个是英语，一个是威尔士语。而且很难读。这是一个充满争议的温床，对吧？英语和威尔士语之间的差距有多大？我的意思是，我完全不知道它听起来是什么样，看起来是什么样。
Yeah, you can talk a little bit in Welsh, just so we can hear it. I'll just get, one of the oldest poems in Welsh is about 600 BC. And it just says, Goyraith, Gatraith of Frayth, Glastferi Hankuina, Gwai, and Gwadi Eluch,
对，你可以用威尔士语说一点，好让我们听听。我只拿，威尔士最古老的诗歌之一大约写于公元前 600 年。它只是说，Goyraith, Gatraith of Frayth, Glastferi Hankuina, Gwai, and Gwadi Eluch,
to Eluch, Thouelch, Tao Eluch thee. It's Lord of the Rings, the Elves. It's how the Elves speak in Lord of the Rings. Yes, well, Tolkien based Elfish on Welsh.
to Eluch, Thouelch, Tao Eluch thee. 这就是《指环王》，精灵语。这就是《指环王》里精灵说话的方式。是的，托尔金以威尔士语为基础创造了精灵语。
Oh, I just made that up. Is that true? Oh, yes, are you kidding me? I mean, I'm a 54-year-old man that is not living in a cave. Why have I never ever heard Welsh? It's a golden cave. Let's be honest.
哦，我刚刚那是瞎编的。是真的吗？哦，是的，你在开玩笑吗？我的意思是，我是一个不住在山洞里的 54 岁男人。为什么我从来没有听说过威尔士语？这是一个金色的山洞。老实说。
Well, yes, a beautiful cave. I've heard tell. Yes, one cave to bind us all. Why? What, I don't understand how that's gone by me. Well, I do. Well, I think, listen, I don't want to get into on the English bashing soapbox, but the English, you know, if we're going to, we'll do with a quick history, the English did their best to kind of eradicate all the Celtic languages for the Scots, the Irish, the Welsh, the Cornish, you know, they, they weren't too Celtic friendly. So there was a lot of stamping out of the language in the culture. Wow.
好吧，是的，一个美丽的山洞。我听说过。是的，一个统治一切的山洞。为什么？什么，我不明白这怎么能从我身边溜走。好吧，我明白。嗯，我想，听吧，我不想陷入抨击英国人的肥皂盒演说中，但英国人，你知道的，如果我们要做，我们来做个简短的历史回顾，英国人尽了最大努力来根除所有凯尔特语言，苏格兰人、爱尔兰人、威尔士人、康沃尔人，你知道的，他们对凯尔特人可不太友好。所以当时对语言和文化的压制非常多。哇。
And was it influenced by folks more northern? Like, was there a Viking influence to all of those Celtic languages? I mean, there's the great evolutionist, Germanic-based. And then, you know, I think the Celtoy were a Spanish tribe initially. And they, you know, then the goals got involved and amalgamated. And then they set up camp in Britain and then the Romans came. We're all such babies here in America. Well, you don't learn any.
它受到更北方的人的影响吗？比如，所有这些凯尔特语言中都有维京人的影响吗？我的意思是，伟大的演化是基于日耳曼语系的。然后，你知道，我认为凯尔特人最初是一个西班牙部落。他们，你知道的，高卢人后来也参与进来并融合了。然后他们在英国安营扎寨，接着罗马人来了。我们在美国都像婴儿一样幼稚。好吧，你什么也没学。
Even if you did pay attention, you know, even if you did in America go to school, not on a massage bus, you learned, you learned, you learned history. How dare you. You learned history. But at least in Canada, we did, we had to take British history.
即使你真的集中注意力了，你知道的，即使你在美国上过学，不是在按摩巴士上，你也学过，学过，学过历史。你好大的胆子。你学过历史。但至少在加拿大，我们上过，我们必须学习英国历史。
So we knew we, oh, we were always studying a fucking battle of collodin and all that shit. Like, was the, is the empire still stamped down your throat in Canada? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, of course. I mean, I don't, I haven't lived there in 30 years. This is a guy who reads World War II books on the can, going to bed. It's not as bad as Justin Thoreau who will watch World War II documentaries through the facehole of a massage table on his iPhone.
所以我们知道我们，哦，我们一直在研究什么卡洛登战役和所有这些狗屎。加拿大是不是依然把帝国主义历史硬塞进你们的喉咙？哦，对，对，对，当然。我的意思是，我已经在那里住了 30 年了。这家伙在马桶上、在睡觉前看二战书籍。这没有贾斯汀·特鲁多那么糟糕，他会通过按摩床的面孔洞用 iPhone 观看二战纪录片。
Okay? He takes it to a new level, this lust for World War II. And he lines it just for comfort and stuff. He lines it with his discarded sleeves just to protect his face. Just to pad the ring. So, Matthew, so you're in, you're what? You're sort of 17. and you go to Rada.
好吗？他对二战的热情达到了一个新的高度。他用丢弃的袖子把它垫起来，只是为了保护他的脸。只是为了垫着那个洞。所以，马修，你当时……你几岁？你大约 17 岁，
Yeah, yeah. Rada. The Academy of Dramatic Art in London, which is the preeminent classical acting school in the world. That's what I tell everyone. I was what I've told my parents they allow me to go. It's like everybody who goes to Rada, they'll tell you. And it's the same way with everybody who's ever gone to Oxford,
然后你去了皇家戏剧艺术学院。对，对。皇家戏剧艺术学院。伦敦的皇家戏剧艺术学院，那是世界上最杰出的古典表演学校。这就是我告诉所有人的。这也是我告诉父母并让他们允许我去的理由。就像每个去过皇家戏剧艺术学院的人一样，他们都会告诉你。那些去过牛津大学的人也是如此，
make sure to let that be known. Yes, we'll drop it in. You know, they're all called... You walk in and they've left the honor boards is still up in the foyer. So, like, you know, has Peter O'Toole and Anthony Hopkins. It's incredible. I did a summer course there years ago.
一定要让别人知道这一点。是的，我们会顺便提一下。你知道，他们都叫……你走进去，荣誉榜仍然挂在前厅里。所以，你知道，上面有彼得·奥图尔和安东尼·霍普金斯。这太不可思议了。我多年前在那里上过一个暑期课程。
Did you? In 1987. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Shakespeare? Yeah, I did the whole thing for a few years there. Yeah. Come on. Come on.
是吗？在 1987 年。对，对，对。莎士比亚？对，我在那里上了好几年的全套课程。对。得了吧。得了吧。
At Rada. I sure did. How was that? It was amazing, man. What did you do? You seem so dumb. It was amazing. Is there a lot of pressure
在皇家戏剧艺术学院。我当然去过。感觉怎么样？太棒了，老兄。你做了什么？你看起来这么笨。太棒了。压力大吗？
when you go to a school like that to make it? I mean, obviously, you did. But, I mean, is there just sort of culturally, do you feel they're like, oh my God, okay, so I'm in Rada now. I got to, I got to maintain our batting average. Or is there a lot of people that go there and then go into other fields? Is that more common? It is, it is.
当你去这样一所学校想要成功时？我的意思是，显然你做到了。但是，我的意思是，从文化角度来看，你会觉得他们就像，哦，天哪，好吧，我现在在皇家戏剧艺术学院了。我得，我得保持我们的击球平均水平。还是有很多人去那里然后进入其他领域的？那个更常见吗？是的，是的。
It's a very small intake. There's only 30 to each year, 15 men, 15 women. Every year. Yeah, yeah. So it's very small. So you feel the pressure immediately. That's small. Did they do it on a bus?
招生人数非常少。每年只有 30 人，15 个男学员，15 个女学员。每年。对，对。所以人数非常少。所以你马上就能感受到压力。他们是在巴士上招生的吗？
Yes, like a massage bus. Yeah, it just kind of goes around, around to Picadilly circus. We have 30 on the massage bus comfortably. That's what I heard. And then you guys stop for lunch at Jinkies on Ventura, right? Yeah, I mentioned that. Some reading at the Bodie Tree. But it's very exclusive.
是的，就像按摩巴士一样。对，它就绕着皮卡迪利广场兜圈子。我们的按摩巴士上舒适地坐着 30 个人。我就是这么听说的。然后你们在文图拉的 Jinkies 停下来吃午饭，对吧？对，我提到了。在菩提树书店看书。但它是非常专属的。
But here you are, you're a kid from Cardiff. Were you the only Welsh person in your year? Yes, I was. I was. I had a friend who was a year older, and then Michael Sheen had just come through. and kind of blazed a trail and was kind of, you know,
但你就在这里，你是个来自加的夫的孩子。你是你那一届里唯一的威尔士人吗？是的，我是。我是。我有一个大我一年的朋友，然后迈克尔·辛刚刚毕业，
setting the west end on fire. So there was this, you know, there was a, the flag of Wales is the dragon. So there was a kind of a dragon firmly stamped as to, you know, the Welsh are resurging again. But, you know, like I said, Anthony Hopkins was the chairman of the board at the time.
开辟了一条道路，并且差不多在……西区引起了轰动。所以有一种，威尔士的国旗是红龙。所以有一条红龙坚定地印在那里，你知道的，威尔士人正在卷土重来。但是，就像我说的，安东尼·霍普金斯当时是董事会主席。
So he'd beat in and out and he'd just done shadow lands. So, you know, there was this, there was this great air that, you know, anything was possible. really. I think one of the things that the Welsh and Wales suffered from enormously is small person syndrome.
所以他进进出出，他刚刚拍完《影子大地》。所以，你知道，有一种伟大的氛围，你知道，一切皆有可能。真的。我认为威尔士人和威尔士遭受的巨大痛苦之一就是小人物综合征。
And at that time, there was just this little bubble of a few Welsh people doing incredibly while Catherine Zito was bursting to the ranks. So I was there at this Renaissance when anything felt possible. You know what my question is going to be? I can ask it now or later.
当时，有那么一小撮威尔士人表现得不可思议，而凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯也正在崛起。所以我当时正处于那个感觉一切皆有可能的文艺复兴时期。你知道我要问什么问题吗？我现在问还是待会儿问？
Did you ever forget a line on stage? What's your favorite theater story, Matthew? Yeah, because you've got to have one or two. Yes, I I have quite a few, in fact. No, but possibly when I was, because I was doing theatre for the first, well, five years, solidly. And then at 25, I thought I got the role that was going to change my life and my career. It didn't.
你在舞台上忘过词吗？马修，你最喜欢的剧院故事是什么？是的，因为你肯定得有一两个。是的，我有好几个，事实上。没有，不过可能是在我，因为我连续演了五年戏剧，扎扎实实地演了五年。然后在25岁时，我想我得到了那个将改变我的人生和职业生涯的角色。然而并没有。
But I got to play Benjamin Braddock in a stage adaptation of The Graduate with Kathleen Turner as my Mrs. Robinson. Wow. And to me, it was the first real introduction to Hollywood because I'd never experienced anything like it in every sense. Like, PAs, and I was like, what's a P.A? Who has a P.A? It was just incredible. Anyway, fast forward.
但我得以在舞台改编版的《毕业生》中饰演本杰明·布拉док，凯瑟琳·特纳饰演我的鲁宾逊太太。哇。对我来说，这是我第一次真正接触好莱坞，因为我在各方面都从未经历过这样的事。比如，制片助理，我当时想，什么是制片助理？谁会有制片助理？简直不可思议。不管怎样，快进。
Halfway through the run, it got a little, you know, there were a few bedroom antics in, in the production, and there's one moment where I jump in bed and with simulating sex. And I have to kind of plunge my face between her legs as if I'm,
演到一半的时候，你知道的，有点，你知道的，制作中加入了一些卧室戏码，有一个镜头是我跳上床模拟性爱。我得把脸埋在她的双腿之间，就好像我在，
I'm pleasuring her. Sure, sure. She did have the, you know, the obligatory kind of, you know, flesh-toned underwear on. But anyway, I had a streaming head cold. Sure.
我在取悦她。当然，当然。她确实穿着那种，你知道的，例行公事的、肉色的内衣。但不管怎样，我当时正患着严重的重感冒。当然。
And being the malicious vindictive type that I am, I wouldn't let the end of study go on. So I went on and I had, my nose is just streaming. My nose is streaming. And I couldn't, I didn't want to kind of sniff heavily during, you know, during dialogue. So I'm doing this.
带着我这种恶毒且记仇的性格，我可不会让演出就这么罢休。所以我上台了，我的鼻子一直在流涕。我的鼻子在流涕。我不想在念台词的时候发出很重的吸鼻涕声。所以我一边这么做。
Yeah, and I go, oh, I know what I know what I'll do. I'll just clear my nose in that quiet, when I'm between, I know, and I did, well, I didn't think. So I jumped in, and I'm between Ms. Turner's legs, and I just went, and inhaled deeply, and the covers kind of shot up. And she's looking down me, like, what the fuck? What the fuck are you doing? And I was like, oh, oh, no, I'm not, no, I'm not, I'm not sniff, I'm not, I have a cold,
对，我说，哦，我知道我要怎么做了。我只要在那个安静的空当，当我处于，我知道的时候清理一下鼻子，我确实这么做了，我没多想。所以我跳了上去，我正处在特纳女士的双腿之间，我直接就，深深地吸了一口气，被子一下子弹了起来。她低头看着我，心想，他妈的怎么回事？你他妈在干什么？我当时就想，哦，不，我不是，不，我不是，我不是在吸，我不是，我感冒了，
I have a cold, I'm not saving you. You're not trying wine out. No, no. No, my God, no way. Yes, I always live with this deep regret of that moment. That and when someone, there was a paparazzi photo, in the moment she took off her robe, and this paparazzi photographer stood up and photographed her,
我感冒了，我不是在救你。你不是在试酒。不，不。不，天哪，绝对没有。是的，我对那个时刻一直怀有深深的悔恨。还有那一次，当有人，有狗仔队拍了一张照片，就在她脱下长袍的那一刻，这个狗仔摄影师站起来拍了她，
and a big flash went off, I know. And I looked at her on stage in this moment, and I was like, oh, we should stop. And she came in with the next line. And I always remember thinking, regardless that she was an consummate professional, I'm going to come in with the next line, I'm going to carry on.
闪光灯闪了一下，我懂的。当时我在舞台上看着她，心想，哦，我们该停下来。而她接着念了下一句台词。我总是记得自己当时想，不管她是一个多么完美的专业演员，我要接上下一句台词，我要继续演下去。
I bitterly regret in that moment not stopping the production, because the next day in a tabloid newspaper, there was a huge photograph of, yeah. Yeah, I was ashamed. Oh, my God. Well, you know. But it was.
我无比后悔当时没有停下演出，因为第二天的小报上，有一张巨大的照片，是的。是的，我很羞愧。哦，天哪。好吧，你知道的。但确实如此。
And the headline just said, Welshman, you know, just fucking coweres under pressure. Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah, yes. Spineless Welshman does nothing. We'll leave it to the English tabloids to say that. Yeah, I love that. Oh, my God. So Matthew, so you did, as you said, did, did you play another great Welshman.
而头条新闻只写着，威尔士人，你知道的，在压力下他妈的只会畏缩。是的， yeah， yeah， yes。无脊椎的威尔士人什么也不做。这种话也就留给英国小报来说吧。是的，我喜欢这个。哦，天哪。所以马修，所以正如你所说，你演过，演过另一个伟大的威尔士人。
You played Dylan Thomas, didn't you? I did. At one point? Yes. Oh my God, if you feel so long ago. About 12 years ago now, yeah. He had this incredible moment, the poet Dylan Thomas had this incredible moment in his life where he was having an affair.
你演过迪伦·托马斯，对吧？我演过。曾经吗？是的。哦天哪，感觉已经好久以前了。大约12年前了，是的。诗人迪伦·托马斯在他的生平中有过这样一个不可思议的时刻，当时他正卷入一场婚外情。
That part was played by Kira Knightley and Cernabiller's playing my wife. and Killion Murphy is the husband of Kieraniteley and this is all true that he burst in on Dylan Thomas
那个角色由凯拉·奈特莉扮演，西娜·米勒扮演我的妻子。基里安·墨菲是凯拉·奈特莉的丈夫，这一切都是真的，他拿着机枪冲进迪伦·托马斯家，
with a machine gun because it was during the Second War he came in with the machine gun he opened fire and then missed everyone and took out a grenade
因为那是二战期间，他拿着机枪闯进来，开枪射击，结果谁也没打中，掏出了一枚手雷，
pulled the pin and the grenade didn't go off and it was that story that we told in the age of love yeah it was an unbelievable
拉开了引信，结果手雷没有爆炸，我们就是在《爱的边缘》里讲述了这个故事，是的，这是一个难以置信的，
story that he survived and then tragically drank himself to death. Wow. Talk about the worst assassin you could ever imagine. Yes. And I was like, talking to killing about it. I was like, but you're playing a commando.
他活了下来，后来却悲惨地酗酒致死的故事。哇。简直可以说是你能想象到的最糟糕的刺客。是的。当时我和基里安谈起这件事。我说，但你演的是一个突击队员。
You're a trained commando. Do you want to play this part? So you are not, you do not live in Wales, correct? I do not know. I now live in leafy Brooklyn. Leafy Brooklyn. Yeah, so you live in Brooklyn, but you come over, you do theater, as you say,
你是一个受过训练的突击队员。你想演这个角色吗？所以你，你不住在威尔士，对吧？我不住。我现在住在绿树成荫的布鲁克林。绿树成荫的布鲁克林。是的，所以你住在布鲁克林，但你飞过来，正如你所说，做戏剧，
for basically five years. And then you move over to, America to do what? What was the first thing that brought you over? The first thing I did, I was doing a play. I was actually doing a two-hander at the Royal Court with Paul Bettany called One More Wasted Year, and everyone called it
基本上做了五年。然后你搬去了，美国是为了做什么？把你带过来的第一件事是什么？我做的第一件事，我当时在演一出戏。我实际上在皇家宫剧院和保罗·贝坦尼一起演了一部双人戏，叫《又一个被浪费的年头》，每个人都把它叫做，
One More Wasted Evening, because it wasn't good. My own family said as much. It was terrible. Didn't they really? So they come backstage, what were they saying to you backstage? My uncle was the first person of the entire group and they came in and is an old sea captain, very salty, and he went, well, that was
《又一个被浪费的夜晚》，因为它不好。我自己的家人也这么说。太糟糕了。真的吗？他们来到后台，在后台对你说什么了？我叔叔是整个团队里第一个走进来的人，他是个老船长，满嘴粗话，他说，嗯，那真是，
shit. Yeah. And I couldn't argue. I went, you're absolutely right. And then, yeah. Stephen Daughery, who was the artistic director at the time,
一团狗屎。是的。而我无法反驳。我说，你绝对说得对。然后，是的。当时艺术总监斯蒂芬·多尔德，
and Press Knight came in, went, darlings, was it the play we need to see right now? Probably not. Should we go to a party? That's hysterical. Oh, wow.
还有普雷斯·奈特走进来，说，亲爱的，那是我们现在需要看的戏吗？大概不是。我们要去参加派对吗？太滑稽了。哦，哇。
That's so hardcore. So you come over with Paul Bettney, you do that. Sorry, yes. Yeah, an American agent came to see the play and he said, Do you want to come over for pilot season? And I'd no idea what it was.
太硬核了。所以你和保罗·贝坦尼一起来的，你演了那个。抱歉，是的。是的，一个美国经纪人来看了这出戏，他说，你想来参加试播集季吗？我根本不知道那是什么。
And I said yes, and then came to L.A. And then the first audition he set me up with, it was Julie Tameau's first movie, Titus, with Anthony Hopkins and Jessica Lang. And I just thought, oh, my God, Los Angeles is truly the promised land where you just turn up and get these huge movies and everything's great.
我说好，然后就来到了洛杉矶。然后他给我安排的第一个试镜，是朱莉·泰莫的第一部电影《提图斯》，由安东尼·霍普金斯和杰西卡·兰格主演。我当时就想，哦，天哪，洛杉矶真的是应许之地，你只要出现就能接到这种大电影，一切都棒极了。
Yeah, you just sign up. And then I did that, yeah. And I shot that in Rome for six months, and then I went back to L.A. and didn't get a job for a decade. Yeah. I thought here's another time my career is going to be made and it was just like
是的，你只要签约就行了。然后我拍了那个，是的。我在罗马拍了六个月，然后回到了洛杉矶，十年没找到工作。是的。我以为这是又一次要成就我职业生涯的时候，结果就像是，
yeah just paid a few bills isn't that amazing I love that feeling of it like yeah it's gonna be like this forever yeah yeah
是的，只是付了几张账单。难道这不神奇吗？我喜欢那种感觉，就像是，是的，会一直这样下去的。
it's like the Klondike I arrived who's like the Klondike where they throw you these scripts and go this is being made for MGM with this as a lead and you're like oh my and you're allowing me
这就像克朗代克淘金热，我刚到的时候就像克朗代克，他们把这些剧本扔给你，说这是为米高梅制作的，由你担任主角，你会想，哦，我的天哪，你竟然允许
to audition for this this is madness all I have to do is get the part and I'm set for life you never know anything you really don't I mean look at us three morons Like, we've, each of us have had great success, as I knock on wood,
我去试镜这个，这太疯狂了。我所要做的就是得到这个角色，我这辈子就稳了。你永远猜不到任何事，你真的猜不到。我是说，看看我们这三个笨蛋。就像我们每个人的职业生涯都取得了巨大的成功，敲木头，
we're super grateful for in our careers. But then, you know, this thing comes along. It's more successful than anything we've ever done. And it was just us three idiots chatting during COVID. Right. The world basically was saying, we don't want you guys to do the thing that you think that you're going to just... Yeah, the things you're professional are.
我们对此超级感激。但接着，你知道，这个东西出现了。它比我们做过的任何事情都要成功。而这不过是我们三个白痴在疫情期间聊天而已。对吧。全世界基本上都在说，我们不希望你们去做你们以为自己会去……是的，你们认为是自己专业的事情。
Yeah, you can keep doing that a little bit if you want. But we just want you to be that you're... We want to hear your idiotic thoughts on stupid shit. Yeah. Just like wonder at the moment where Sean learns that whales was, you know where whales got its name, Sean? You know, that's where they made the first harpoon. That's not true.
是的，如果你想的话，你可以稍微继续做那个。但我们只想让你们……我们想听听你们对愚蠢事情的弱智想法。是的。就像惊叹于肖恩得知威尔士是，你知道威尔士名字的由来吗，肖恩？你知道，那是他们制造第一个鱼叉的地方。这不是真的。
That's not true. It's not true. Correct. But you bought it for a second. And that's what they tune in to here. Because he'll fuck with me and he'll say something that's completely not true and then he'll say something that's completely true. I never know what to believe.
这不是真的。这不是真的。没错。但你有一秒钟相信了。这就是他们收听节目的原因。因为他会耍我，他会说一些完全不是真的话，然后他又会说一些完全是真的话。我永远不知道该相信什么。
It's tough. I know, Angel. But wait a minute. They did shoot Moby Dick in Wales with Gregory Peck. And my grandfather worked on it. Is that true? Is that true? Yeah, they built three large rubber whales.
这很难。我知道，安琪。但等一下。他们确实在威尔士和格利高里·派克一起拍摄了《白鲸》。我外公还在那儿工作过。那是真的吗？那是真的吗？是的，他们建造了三头巨大的橡胶鲸鱼。
And one of them, I know, this is the great joke. It's like they came to Wales. And one of them sailed off into the Irish Sea, which I think is fantastic. I have a whale that needs a rubber, but go ahead. Hey-oh. Ooh. My grandfather caught Moby Dick, but there's a cure for it now.
其中一头，我知道，这是一个伟大的笑话。就像他们来到威尔士。其中一头游进了爱尔兰海，我觉得这太棒了。我有一头需要橡胶的鲸鱼，不过你继续。嘿呀。哦。我外公抓住了白鲸，但现在有药可以治了。
Hey, oh. Wait, wait, wait. What did your grandfather do on that? His friend Edgar was a carpenter and they kind of helped out in the framing of the whales I love that That's cool
嘿，哦。等等，等等。你外公在上面做什么？他的朋友埃德加是个木匠，他们算是帮忙搭建了鲸鱼的骨架。我喜欢这个。太酷了。
Wait I want to ask about Kerry And I want to know like Did you meet each other Because I'm an idiot I don't know Did you meet before Americans Or on the set And how did that go
等等，我想问关于凯丽的事。我想知道，你们是彼此认识的吗？因为我是个白痴，我不知道。你们是在美国人之前认识的，还是在片场认识的？进展得怎么样？
And when did you know the sparks flew Just one question at time We did Because I get easily confused Because I love Carrie I love Carrie So do I We met quite a few years before
你们是什么时候知道火花四溅的？一次只问一个问题。我们认识。因为我很容易糊涂。因为我爱凯丽。我爱凯丽。我也是。我们在好几年前就认识了，
the Americans in Rusty Canyon at a kickball party that Jennifer Gray hosted, and I had no idea what kickball was. Boy, all of that adds up, by the way. Yes, yes. How I just ambled through life, bumping into the furniture and ending up going, how did I get here? How did this happen? And we were the last two to leave. We were in the parking lot, and I was trying to open a bottle of beer for her with a key and failing.
在美国人在峡谷乡村（Rustic Canyon）参加詹妮弗·安妮斯顿举办的一个踢球派对时认识的，我当时根本不知道什么是踢球。天哪，顺便说一句，所有这些加起来都很合理。是的，是的。我是怎么跌跌撞撞地度过一生，撞上家具，最后说，我是怎么到这里来的？这是怎么发生的？我们是最后两个离开的。我们在停车场，我当时正试图用钥匙帮她打开一瓶啤酒，却失败了。
And I asked for her number then. And that was all I can remember. She was moving to New York two days after that on the Tuesday. It was a Sunday. And that's all I sort of remember. And then the road to the Americans was a long, crazy one. And then on the first day of fight training, I said to Kerry, I said, oh, we've met, we've met before, actually. She was like, no, no, we definitely have.
我当时就向她要了电话号码。这就是我能记住的全部了。她在那之后两天，也就是周二，就要搬去纽约了。那是周日。这就是我所能记住的。然后通往《美国谍梦》的道路是一条漫长而疯狂的道路。然后在武术训练的第一天，我对凯丽说，我说，哦，我们见过，我们以前其实见过。她说，不，不，我们绝对见过。
I said, it had been years. He's been years at this point. And I said, yeah, yeah, we met before. We met her a kickball party in Rustic Canyon. She went, I know who you are. and you left me a message on my answering machine, a very drunken message. And I went,
我说，那已经是好几年前的事了。那时候已经是好几年了。我说，对，对，我们以前见过。我们在峡谷乡村的一个踢球派对上见过。她说，我知道你是谁。你在我的答录机上给我留过言，一条非常醉醺醺的留言。我说，
Oh. Did I, I'm so sorry. I had no memory of leaving a long, rambling, incoherent, drunken message, which is probably why I should think of- No way, did you really? Wait, can I be a super moron? Are you guys together?
哦。我有吗？真的很对不起。我完全不记得留过一条又长、又语无伦次、醉醺醺的留言，这可能就是为什么我应该去想——不会吧，你真的留了？等等，我能当个超级大笨蛋吗？你们俩在一起了吗？
Yeah, yeah. Oh, okay. Wait, did you, so you got together, you started working together, that they're just good friends. No, because they worked together on the Americans for six. Cheers.
对，对。哦，好吧。等等，所以你们在一起了，开始一起工作，他们只是好朋友。不，因为他们在《美国谍梦》里合作了六年。干杯。
That's what I'm saying. That's why I was asked. But then, but during that, you guys fell in love, got married, had a kid? We did, yes. Yeah, but I want to know what happens. So she goes, okay, now I remember you. And then what? And then it was, it was just a very, it was a very slow burn.
这就是我要说的。这就是我问的原因。但随后，但在那期间，你们俩坠入爱河，结婚了，还有了个孩子？我们是的，是的。是的，但我相知道发生了什么。所以她说，好吧，现在我想起你是谁了。然后呢？然后，这只是一个非常缓慢的过程。
The first season, you know, I, I think we were both trying to be sworn off to that thing. We're going to go, I'm not going to do what everyone tells us never to do. I'm not going to do that. And then, but the beginning of the second season, it was. It was, it was, it was, yeah. Okay, so now were the producer, did the producers take each of you aside individually and say, hey, this is, you're dealing with an asset here, okay?
第一季的时候，你知道，我，我想我们俩都试图对那件事发誓不碰。我们要说，我不会去做所有人告诉我们绝对不要做的事。我不会那样做。但是，第二季开始的时候，事情就。事情就，事情就，是这样的。好吧，那么当时制片人有没有把你们俩分别叫到一边，说，嘿，听着，你这里处理的是一项重要资产，好吗？
Everyone has jobs. If you guys go south, we have to shut the show down. Were there conversations? No, no, they were very gracious about it, because I've had friends. They were all so nervous. I know, I've had friends who, you know, who've had that conversation to sit down from the producers going,
每个人都有工作。如果你们俩搞砸了，我们得停播。有过这种谈话吗？不，不，他们对此非常大度，因为我有过一些朋友。他们当时都超级紧张。我知道，我有过朋友，你知道的，他们曾和制片人坐下来谈过，制片人说，
look, we've all been down here before. You guys are in you. You're mid-30s now. You know, you're not 22. Right off the company, and they were very, yeah, they were very kind and gracious about it. Do you know, do you know the TV director Tommy Shlami?
听着，我们以前都经历过这些。你们俩正在。你们现在三十五岁左右了。你知道，你们不是22岁了。直截了当地告诉公司，他们对此非常友善和大度。你知道吗，你知道电视导演托米·施拉米（Tommy Schlamme）吗？
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, so Shlami was directing the beginning of the second season, and he has that kind of beautiful voice, but Kerry and I were having a, we're doing a sex scene, and Shlami just goes, these two have been naked together before. Uh-huh.
对，对。是的，所以施拉米当时在导演第二季的开头，他有那种动听的嗓音，但我和凯丽当时在拍，我们在拍一场床戏，施拉米直接就说，这两个人以前一起光过身子。呃-huh。
And they just, it was like, called out. Oh, really? So at that point, no one knew, but he could tell. He could tell. And then there's a longer story as to how we got found out, which was just...
他们就，就像是被当场拆穿了。哦，真的吗？所以当时，没有人知道，但他看出来了。他看出来了。然后关于我们是怎么被发现的，还有一个更长一点的故事，那就是——
We've got time. Well, Kerry got broken into. I was in the house at the time, and the robbers kind of grabbed my backpack, shoved it full of her stuff. You're in the house alone during a home invasion. Yeah, yeah. Wow.
我们有的是时间。好吧，凯丽家遭窃了。我当时就在屋里，劫匪顺手抓了我的背包，把里面塞满了她的东西。你在家里遭遇入室抢劫时独自一人。对，对。哇。
Start there. Well, so here's the other thing is it's early day, and this is just a testament to my abject stupid but with early days of our relationship. And she wakes me up, she says, there's someone in the house. And I go, no, there's not.
从这开始讲。好吧，所以还有一件事是，那是早期，这简直证明了我的极度愚蠢，但那是在我们关系的早期。她把我叫醒，说，屋里有人。我说，不，没有。
And then I just heard this voice. Oh, shit. And I remember thinking, in any logical moment, you'd go, let's lock ourselves in the bathroom, call 911. And for some stupid reason, because it were very early days, I thought, what I do next, she will judge me on for the rest of our lives. What's that film? Force majeure.
然后我只听到一个声音。哦，该死。我记得当时想，在任何理智的时刻，你都会想，我们把自己锁在浴室里，拨打911。出于某些愚蠢的原因，因为那是我们关系的早期，我想，我接下来做的事，她会在我们余下的人生中对我评头论足。那是哪部电影？《游客》。
Force major. Where the avalanche comes and he just runs. He leaves his family beyond. Right, right? I swear to God. I was like, if I suggest to go into the bathroom, call 911, will she think me a coward? Your relationship's over.
《不可抗力》。雪崩来临时他只顾自己逃跑。他把家人抛在脑后。对，对吧？我向天发誓。我当时想，如果我建议去浴室拨打911，她会认为我是个懦夫吗？你们的感情就结束了。
Yes. I had all these weird things going to my head. So what did I do? She had a working fireplace in the bedroom. So I picked up the poker. Sure. And with not a stitch on me, I walked out to meet my fate. Oh, God.
是的。我脑子里闪过所有这些奇怪的念头。所以我做了什么？她的卧室里有一个正在使用的壁炉。所以我拿起了火钳。当然。而且一丝不挂，我走了出去，去迎接我的命运。哦，天哪。
Wow. And we'll be right back after these messages. Okay, so now we're back. So now we're back. So now you're... So after eight months of treatment, yes. I was fine. No, I'm kidding.
哇。广告回来，我们马上继续。好了，现在我们回来了。所以现在我们回来了。所以现在你是……在接受了八个月的治疗后，是的。我没事。不，我开玩笑的。
So did you face to face with this fella? No, because what I did was, I think, what most people do is you turn the light on, and they run straight away. Right. So I heard them kind of run, and they ran out the front door. Oh, thank God. I know.
所以你和这家伙面对面了吗？没有，因为我做的事，我想，是大多数人都会做的事，你一开灯，他们立刻就跑了。对。所以我听到他们跑了，他们从前门跑出去了。哦，谢天谢地。我知道。
I know. Jesus. So you do this and now Kerry thinks that you're her hero? I wouldn't go that far. Or did she think you were stupid for chasing up to the guy? She was locked in the bathroom. Yeah, calling guy one. Yeah.
我知道。天哪。所以你做了这个，现在凯丽觉得你是她的英雄？我不会走得那么远。还是她觉得你追上去很蠢？她被锁在浴室里。对，打911。对。
Then seven cops turn up and they start, they clock her and they're like looking. They'll have no idea why, but they're looking at her. And then all of a sudden the DA were like, they catch them and the DA said, oh, I tell you what, we would love to return your belongings on set with a photographer to Kerry. if that's okay. And she's like, she wasn't wild about the idea. Try to put it on.
然后七个警察出现了，他们开始，他们盯上了她，看着她。他们完全不知道为什么，但他们看着她。然后突然地方检察官说，他们抓住了他们，地方检察官说，哦，跟你说吧，如果可以的话，我们很乐意带着摄影师把你的财物送回片场给凯丽。她当时对此并不是很热衷。试着把它推掉。
No, no, no, because the DA was retiring that year. He wanted kind of a, you know, hero ending. So the NYPD, come on set with a photographer, and then they're holding up my bag. And, indeed, one of the young PA's went, wait, that's not Kerry's bag. That's Matthew's bag.
不，不，不，因为地方检察官那一年就要退休了。他想要一个，你知道的，英雄般的结局。所以纽约警察局带着摄影师来到片场，然后他们举起我的包。而且，事实上，其中一个年轻的制片助理说，等等，这不是凯丽的包。那是马修的包。
And as I'm running, trying to go, shut the fuck up. And that's how the crew kind of found out. No. Wow. Wow, wow, wow. Yeah. That's crazy.
而我正跑过来，试图说，闭上你他妈的嘴。剧组就是这样发现的。不。哇。哇，哇，哇。是的。太疯狂了。
It was a lot to go through just for the big reveal. Wow. That's kind of cool. So then this guy managed to grab a few things before he went running. He did. He did. Wow. And when I saw the picture, when he was arrested, I said, oh, I said, look, there's a picture of the guy that caught him.
为了这个大揭秘，经历的事情可真不少。哇。这挺酷的。所以这家伙在逃跑前设法抓了几件东西。他拿了。他拿了。哇。当我看到他被捕时的照片时，我说，哦，我说，看，那是抓住他的那家伙的照片。
I said, look, he's been cuffed by two little tiny cops. She said, they're not tiny. And I saw the size of him. He could have turned me. into a kebab with that poker and done what he wanted. I wouldn't have had it. Now, did you have any sort of war cry
我说，看，他被两个小小的警察戴上手铐了。她说，他们可不小。我看了一下他的体型。他本可以用那个火钳把我变成一个烤肉串，想对我做什么就对我做什么。我根本无力招架。现在，你有没有发出什么战吼，
as you turned on the light? Was there any sort of get the heck out of you? You're going, hey bear. Hey, boy. You know. Was there any of that? No, no.
当你打开灯的时候？有没有什么诸如“给我滚出去”之类的？你当时在喊，嘿，熊。嘿，伙计。你知道的。有那种东西吗？没有，没有。
As much as I have a poker. Yeah, yeah. As much as I love that moment in Gladiator and all the Celts kind of attack the Romans and I always think, you know, if it came to it, that's how I'd react. I was not,
尽管我拿着火钳。是的，是的。尽管我很喜欢《角斗士》里的那一幕，所有凯尔特人一拥而上攻击罗马人，我总是想，如果真的到了那个地步，我就会那样反应。我当时并不是，
I couldn't move. my legs. Don't make me come down there. Yeah, yes. I'm classically trained, you know. I've done fencing. Totally naked. Yes. Let's get this going. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. All right, so you and Carrie have a child. That's a boy or a girl. He's a boy. He's a boy. Carrie has two older ones. So there's three, you know,
我的双腿动弹不得。别逼我下去。是的，是的。我是受过正统训练的，你知道的。我练过击剑。一丝不挂。是的。我们开始吧。对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。好吧，所以你和凯丽有个孩子。是个男孩还是女孩。是个男孩。是个男孩。凯丽有两个大一点的孩子。所以家里有三个，你知道，
there's three in the house who outnumber us. And what are the ages of all three? 15, 11, and 6. 15, 11, and 6. Then the 15 and 11 are boy girl? A boy girl, so it was boy girl boy. Boy girl, boy. And how are you liking being a dad? I love it.
家里有三个，人数上压倒了我们。这三个孩子的年龄分别多大？15岁、11岁和6岁。15、11和6。那15岁和11岁的是男孩女孩？一个男孩一个女孩，所以是男孩、女孩、男孩。男孩、女孩、男孩。你觉得当爸爸感觉怎么样？我很喜欢。
Do you love it? I do love it. It's the madness that I love. It's when it's most catastrophic, the small stuff irks you, but when it's catastrophic, it's brilliant. When those mornings, when the wheels so royally come off, that's when I can sit back and go,
你真的很喜欢吗？我真的很喜欢。我喜欢的是那种疯狂。当事情最糟糕、小事惹恼你的时候，但当事情变得一团糟时，那就太棒了。当那些早晨，当生活彻底乱套的时候，正是我可以坐下来心想，
oh, this is just brilliant. Who's the more patient one with all of the, with the chaos? Is it you or her? Her. Yeah. Chaos I'm fine with. But manners, like rudeness, I don't tolerate.
哦，这简直太棒了。面对这一切混乱，谁更有耐心？是你还是她？她。是的。混乱我能应付。但礼貌，比如无礼，我是容不下的。
And that's when I... No, me neither. Yeah. No, that's what I can. How old are yours now, Jason? I got 16 and 11, two girls. Oh, wow. Yeah.
每当那种时候……不，我也是。是的。不，那就是我可以。杰森，你的孩子们现在多大了？我有16岁和11岁的两个女孩。哦，哇。是的。
And I'm totally permissive and the guy that plays around and I don't have to really be the disciplinarian. But if it's the rudeness, if it's stuff like that, and I just like the switch gets thrown. Yeah, same. I pick and choose my moments. Yeah, the chaos is great. Yeah, rudeness I have.
我完全是个放任型的父亲，是个陪他们玩的家伙，我真的不用扮演严厉管教的角色。但如果是无礼，如果是诸如此类的事情，我就会像开关被拨动了一样。是的，我也是。我会挑时候发作。是的，混乱很棒。是的，无礼我是受不了的。
Yeah, we've got, we've got 14, 12, and then my partner, she's a five-year-old, and then we have an almost three-year-old. Oh, wow. All boys, all boys. No way. Yeah. You've almost got the hockey team. Almost got the team, and it's the fuck, and it is, sometimes it is absolute, just abject chaos.
是的，我们有14岁、12岁的，然后我伴侣那边，她有一个五岁的，然后我们还有一个快三岁的。哦，哇。全是男孩，全是男孩。不会吧。是的。你几乎可以组建一个冰球队了。几乎组建了一支队伍，而且这他妈的，有时候这绝对是，纯粹的、彻底的混乱。
Like just... How do you like it? I love it. The chaos. It's great. Yeah, I love it. It's, I don't know. I just wouldn't have it any other way.
就像只是……你觉得怎么样？我喜欢。这种混乱。太棒了。是的，我喜欢。我不知道。我绝不会希望它是别的样子。
I embrace it. It's fun. Same thing. They're all nice kids and everybody, you know, has good manners and stuff. That's one of the things. But I love it, man. I love it when it just gets absolute, you know, sometimes when you get into the witching hour sort of near bedtime, it gets fucking bonkers.
我全盘接受。这很有趣。同感。他们都是好孩子，每个人，你知道的，都很有礼貌什么的。这是其中一点。但我喜欢，老兄。我喜欢当它变得绝对，你知道的，有时当你接近就寝时间进入那种“巫婆时刻”时，就会变得疯狂无比。
Yeah. How about the complications, Matthew, of travel and stuff? Since you guys are both very active in your careers and your kids are now deeply entrenched in school and having that sort of social and academic continuity, like you can't really pick them up and take them places with you as much as you want, I'll bet, right? How do you guys manage that?
旅行之类的麻烦呢，马修？既然你们俩的职业生涯都非常活跃，而且你们的孩子现在也已经深深融入了学校，有着那种社交和学业上的连续性，所以你不可能真的像你希望的那样随时把他们带在身边四处奔波，我敢打赌，对吧？你们是怎么处理这一点的？
Is it easy or tough? It is tough. I mean, we try and live by this ridiculous rule where one of us works, one of us doesn't and that, you know, kids stay at school. Right. But it's just... That never works out, right? Because, like, what if somebody gets a great, great call?
是很容易还是很难？确实很难。我的意思是，我们尽量遵循这样一个荒谬的规则：我们中一个人工作，另一个不工作，这样，你知道的，孩子们就能留在学校。对。但这只是……这从来不管用，对吧？因为，比如，如果有人接到一个非常非常棒的邀约呢？
And it's, you just can't say no, but this is your turn and, you know. Yeah, this is what happened last year. Grandma came in and, you know, the kids ate sugar for six solid months. They loved it. I think that my sort of view on it always is that, is that you have this idea of how you want it to go. So you say, like, one of us is going to work, one of us, not, whatever that thing is, and you try to set those parameters and you try to get as close to it as you can. And you have to be flexible and allow yourself to, you know, that there are going to be moments where it's just pure chaos.
而你就是无法拒绝，但这次轮到你了，你知道的。是的，这就是去年发生的事情。外婆来了，你知道的，孩子们连续六个月都在吃糖。他们爱死啦。我想我对这件事的看法一直是，你对事情的发展有一个理想化的设想。所以你会说，比如，我们中一个人去工作，另一个不去，不管那是什么规矩，你试着设定这些参数，并尽量做到最好。你必须保持灵活，并允许自己去接受，你知道的，有些时刻就是纯粹的混乱。
Yes. And the trip is kids are so incredibly resilient. Like they don't know any different. You know, I grew up in a house where my mom was a stewardess for Pan Am or flight attendant. She was gone two weeks of every month. It was just normal to me, you know, just had my mom half the time. And that was just normal. Yeah.
是的。而且孩子们有着难以置信的适应力。就像他们不知道有什么不同。你知道的，我在一个那样的家庭里长大，我妈妈是泛美航空的乘务员或空姐。她每个月有两周不在家。这对我很正常，你知道的，我只有一半时间有妈妈。这很正常。是的。
I had my dad. No, no, no, Matthew's going to love this story. No, no, yeah, go. So it starts with a Chevy Pontiac, the engine turning on. Yeah, and it ends with a peel out. Yeah, just a peel out. And a real... And a sort of a distant kind of, fuck you.
我有爸爸。不，不，不，马修一定会喜欢这个故事的。不，不，讲吧。故事是从一辆雪佛兰庞蒂亚克发动机启动开始的。是的，以一个急转飙车结束。是的，就是急转飙车。还有一个真正的……还有一种遥远的，去你的。
Fuck y'all. Fuck all you. I'm out. This is John, this isn't true, is it? Yeah, it's true. My dad left him. That's five. And he left his mom to keep an eye on all of them.
去你们所有人的。老子不干了。肖恩，这不是真的吧？是的，是真的。他爸爸抛弃了他们。那是五个。他留下他妈妈看着他们所有。
And I stress and I. His mother has one eye. And I'd stress and I. Matthew, it's brilliantly tragic. Traged. You have to laugh. It's fun. Yeah.
我强调一下，我。他妈妈只有一只眼睛。我强调一下，我。马修，这真是悲剧性的精彩。悲剧。你得笑。很有趣。是的。
It's the same thing we have to do. We have to laugh at our misfortunes because... But wait, I'm going to ask you a weird question only because you're wearing a black t-shirt. And I've seen a lot of photos of you and stuff where you seem very... You seem very kind of fat... Like, you're into fashion when you have to be...
我们必须做的事也一样。我们必须对我们的不幸付诸一笑，因为……等等，我要问你一个奇怪的问题，只是因为你穿着一件黑色T恤。我见过很多你的照片之类的地方，你看起来非常……你看起来非常……就像你很注重时尚，当你不得不的时候……
Like, I know nothing. Like, I'm terrible. But, like, you're probably like Will... You're probably like Will where you're like, I like to look good when I even go to the store. I like to look good when I go out in public. Like, is that... It seems like a lot of effort. Oh, no. No. If you truly knew me,
就像我什么都不懂。就像我很糟糕。但是，你可能像威尔……你可能像威尔那样，你心里会想，我喜欢即使去商店也看起来不错。我喜欢在公共场合露面时看起来不错。就像，那是……这似乎需要付出很多努力。哦，不。不。如果你真的了解我，
It's, Kerry said the other day, because I have, I have these beaten up car hearts and I wear, usually just the same black t-shirt every day. I even care is like, you've got, you've got to change for the school run. You've won the same thing for, for, it's now, it's now months. Right. And my car hearts are really beaten up and there's, there was this, there was this, what's cards? Car-Harts.
凯丽前几天说，因为我有，我有这些穿破了的卡哈特（Carhartt）工装裤，而且我通常每天都穿同一件黑色T恤。甚至连凯丽都说，你得，你得换身衣服去接孩子。你已经连续几个月，穿同一件衣服了。对。而且我的卡哈特真的破旧不堪，当时有，当时有，什么叫卡哈特？Carharts。
Sorry, it's a brand, clothing brand. Oh, oh, Har- Hearts. It's like, what are all the carpenters wear them and the, and the, Real worker guys. And I wear them into the ground because they look so terrible. I was standing in school pickup in the line and this mother kind of looked at him like Travis
抱歉，这是一个品牌，服装品牌。哦，哦，Har-Hearts。就像，所有的木匠都穿它们，还有那些，真正的工人群体。我把它穿得稀烂，因为它们看起来太糟糕了。我站在学校接孩子的队伍里，有位母亲看了看他，就像特拉维斯那样，
and she said, what is it you do? And I went, oh, I'm actually an actor. And she went, oh, oh. It's like, almost like, why are you wearing car? Why are you masquerading as someone who works for a living? Well, you have your uniform. Well, it's like Jason always gets the question when they see him.
她说，你是做什么的？我说，哦，我其实是个演员。她就说，哦，哦。这感觉就像，你为什么要穿卡哈特？你为什么要假装是一个靠体力劳动谋生的人？好吧，你有你的制服。好吧，这就像杰森每次别人看到他时都会被问到的问题。
They always say, what times are your tea time? Right? Isn't that the question that gets most of the day? Well, when I wear this little outfit, it's clear. You know what I do get a lot, you know what I do get a lot is do you color your hair? And now recently, because of this film where I play in a guy in 1985, they think it's a wig. Just a full-blown wig that I'm wearing. Yeah. I'm looking forward to that immensely.
他们总是问，你们的下午茶时间是几点？对吧？这难道不是他们一天到晚被问得最多的问题吗？好吧，当我穿着这套小行头时，就很清楚了。你知道我经常听到什么吗，你知道我经常听到的一句话是，你染发了吗？最近，因为这部电影，我在里面扮演一个1985年的家伙，他们以为这是个假发。认为我戴的是一顶货真价实的假发。是的。我对那部戏充满了期待。
No one thinks that my hair is the right, is the real color. Because in your 70s like you are, it's nobody that's not true. It's not believed. that a 70-year-old would not have to admit that there have been, I've had a few people in the last year who have asked me, Jason, if you color your hair. Yeah, same.
没有人认为我的头发颜色是对的，是真的颜色。因为在你七十多岁的时候，就像你现在这样，没有人，这不是真的。没人会相信，一个七十岁的人会不承认有，过去一年里有好几个人问过我，杰森，你是不是染头发了。是的，同感。
I tell everyone that you color your hair. It's what I did that, huh? Yes, son of a bitch. It was, yeah, it was during that moment. Do you remember what, do you know, I don't know if you remember this, in the Golden Globes, this is, this is,
我告诉所有人你染头发了。这就是我做的，哈？是的，你个王八蛋。那是，是的，就是在那个时候。你还记得吗，你知道，我不知道你还记得吗，在金球奖上，这是，这是，
perversely pretentious, but it still makes me laugh. That kind of green, the virtual green room, if you remember, is you, me, Bob Odenkirk, Josh O'Connor,
反常地装腔作势，但它依然让我发笑。那种绿色的，虚拟绿后台，如果你还记得的话，是你、我、鲍勃·奥登科克、乔什·奥康纳，
and then we were all waiting for Al Pacino to kind of pop up. Do you remember? Into the virtual green room. We're all waiting. And then he pops up because we're all at home during the pandemic. And he looks like a Bond villain
然后我们都在等待阿尔·帕西诺弹出来。你记得吗？进入虚拟绿后台。我们都在等待。然后他弹出来了，因为我们在大流行期间都在家。他看起来像个邦德反派，
because he has like a small dog in his lap and he's stroking it. Yes. And we all sort of say, we all go, hi, hello. Hello. Hi, hi. And then there's silence.
因为他腿上抱着一只小狗，正在抚摸它。是的。然后我们都说，我们都说，嗨，你好。你好。嗨，嗨。然后是一片寂静。
And then we kind of do a second round we're like going, hello, hi. No, nothing. And then I think you said, I don't think he can hear us. And then Pacino just goes, oh, I can hear you. Oh, boy.
然后我们进行了第二轮，我们像是说，你好，嗨。不，什么都没有。然后我想你说了句，我觉得他听不见我们说话。然后帕西诺直接就说，哦，我能听见你们说话。哦，天哪。
Yeah. We all went, oh. Just doesn't want to do the group high. And then he said, I think he colors his hair. Yeah. Oh, this guy? Oh, oh, hair color.
是的。我们都说，哦。就是不想进行集体问好。然后他说，我觉得他染头发了。是的。哦，这家伙？哦，哦，发色。
Oh, Charlie. Oh. Hey, so, Matthew. Yeah. Quick question for Jason. Why is the emblem? Why is the person holding an umbrella? What is that?
哦，查理。哦。嘿，所以，马修。对。有个关于杰森的快问。为什么那个标志是？为什么那个人拿着一把雨伞？那是什么？
Oh, this is some silly golf sweater. Mary Poppins. Oh yeah, what is that? It actually is a Mary Popp. This is a, I believe this is an ATT thing, Willie. Yeah. From ATT? Yeah, this is one of the...
哦，这是一件愚蠢的高尔夫毛衣。玛丽·波平斯。哦，对，那是什么？这实际上是一件美国电话电报公司（ATT）的东西，威利。是的。来自ATT的？是的，这是其中一件……
From that swag room we went into? Free Swetter. We have smartless golf stuff coming out soon. I love it. Oh, let's take the opportunity to do a merch tie-in, show. That's smart. Thank. Matthew, Matthew, can you commit right now to wearing smartless golf merch on the school run?
来自我们去过的那个礼品发放室？免费毛衣。我们很快就会推出SmartLess高尔夫相关周边了。我喜欢。哦，让我们借此机会做一个周边产品的联动，秀。这很聪明。谢谢。马修，马修，你现在能承诺在去接孩子时穿上SmartLess的高尔夫周边吗？
My entire closet is mainly made up of clothes I've stolen from jobs. I don't buy your thing. Well, we're going to send you some smartless golf swag. I love it. I love it. Some plus fours, right, for the golf pants. You know, you can wear that. Yeah.
我的整个衣柜基本上都是我从工作片场顺来的衣服。我不买你们的东西。好吧，我们会寄给你一些SmartLess的高尔夫周边。我喜欢。我喜欢。还有一条加长四英寸的高尔夫裤，对吧？你可以穿那个。对吧？
You know? We were listening. I do want to say, your show gives us so much joy. And we were listening. Yes, it does. We were listening to it recently. And Will, I think you went to dinner with Sean at Jarr. And Sean, you were.
你知道吗？我们一直在听。我真的想说，你们的节目给我们带来了那么多快乐。我们一直在听。是的，确实如此。我们最近一直在听。而且威尔，我想你和肖恩去Jarr餐厅吃过晚饭。肖恩，你当时在。
Yeah, I was not invited. Yeah. Well, we brought that up in the car. We were like, I wasn't Jason. Yeah. Yeah. I never asked. These guys have been all over the world together.
对，我没有被邀请。是的。我们在车里还提起过这个。我们当时想，我不是杰森。是的。是的。我从来没问过。这些家伙一起去过世界各地。
Oh my gosh. I've been to Turkey. They've been to... Where else guys? Yeah, we have. Where else? Your passport's been stamped. Venice, Italy, right?
哦，天哪。我去过土耳其。他们去过……还有哪里，伙计们？是的，我们去过。还有哪里？你们的护照盖满了章。意大利威尼斯，对吧？
Venis Italy, yeah. You guys play golf every day. Okay, go ahead. Oh, that's different. So you did say that you were wearing ugs. The kind of slipper ugs for dinner. Is that right? Did I remember that right?
意大利威尼斯，是的。你们俩每天都打高尔夫。好吧，你继续。哦，那不一样。所以你确实说过你穿着UGG。那种拖鞋式的UGG去吃晚饭。是这样吗？我没记错吧？
Absolutely, yeah. And I said to Canada, went, see? It's fine! And she went, they live in L.A. Right. She's right. Sean, that was you wearing the comfy? shoes?
绝对的，是的。我对凯娜说，看！这没问题！而她却说，他们住在洛杉矶。对吧。她是正确的。肖恩，那是你穿着舒服的鞋子吗？
He's been doing it for years. He's doing it for years. Who looks at your shoes? Nobody looks at your shoes in a dark restaurant. And then I would choose to never come to dinner with you again. Cobblers around the world. Cobbler's. Listen.
他这么做好多年了。他这么做好多年了。谁会看你的鞋子？在昏暗的餐厅里没人看你的鞋子。然后我会选择再也不跟你一起去吃晚饭了。全世界的鞋匠们。鞋匠们。听着。
So Matthew, so now recently in the last couple of years you've partnered with our good friend Mr. Downey Jr. Oh yeah, Perry Mason. Now that's a handsome looking show. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Talk to us a little bit about that. First of all, how that came about.
马修，那么最近这几年里，你和我们的好朋友小罗伯特·唐尼合作了。噢，对，还有《梅森探长》。那部剧看起来真帅。对，对，对。跟我们聊聊这件事吧。首先，它是怎么促成的。
And what an absolute. absolute terror he is as executive producer. Oh my God. Oh my God. He's been checked. Yells and screaming. Oh, what a screamer.
作为执行制片人，他简直是个绝对的……绝对的恶魔。我的天呐。我的天呐。他被制止了。大喊大叫。噢，真爱大喊大叫。
He strikes people. Yes, yes, with a glove. Has a leather glove, a small gauntlet that he sometimes put a metal thimble in it, just for the little, ah! Yeah. Oh, Christ, he's here, he's here!
他打人。是的，是的，用手套打。戴着皮手套，一个小护手，有时里面还塞个金属顶针，就为了那个，啊！对。噢，天呐，他来了，他来了！
He speaks so highly. How did that come? How did, yeah, he loves you. Yeah, he does. He really does. Robert loves you. And talk to us a little bit about, And Susan as well.
他评价很高。那是怎么促成的？怎么，对，他喜欢你。是的，他确实喜欢。他是真的很喜欢。罗伯特喜欢你。跟我们聊聊，还有苏珊。
Susan does not like, oh, she does. Well, yes. The great Susan, the brains of that duo. It's the wind beneath the wings and the brain and the head. Yeah. How did that come into your sort of into your world, the Perry Mason project? I mean, I'm trying to think what year it was now,
苏珊不喜欢，噢，她喜欢。嗯，是的。伟大的苏珊，那个二人组的大脑。那是振翅欲飞的清风，是智囊和领袖。对。那个《梅森探长》的项目是怎么进入你的，嗯，进入你的世界的？我是说，我现在在想那是哪一年，
because it was a while back. Probably three, four years ago maybe? Yes, yes, yes, yes. And I always, this is, this. This is how my brain works. When my manager calls and he goes, you know, Team Downey would want to talk to you about a reboot, Perry Mason. My first question was like, who's turned it down?
因为那是好久以前了。大概三、四年年前吧？对，对，对，对。我总是，这是，这。这就是我的大脑运作的方式。当我经纪人打电话来说，你知道，唐尼团队想跟你谈谈重启《梅森探长》的事。我的第一反应是：谁拒绝了？
Who's turned it down? Why does it Robert want to do it? Yes, and I think he did. I think that was the whole point that Robert was supposed to do it. And it took them almost 10 years of development. And it went through many, very many guises of a TV film, a series. And I just think Robert never quite got. there.
谁拒绝了？为什么罗伯特想做这个？是的，我想他确实想。我想这就是重点，罗伯特本该演的。他们花了将近10年时间来开发。它经历了很多很多种形式，电视电影、剧集。我只是觉得罗伯特一直没完全搞定。
So yeah, they reached out for a meeting, which I was terrified about. And the brilliant Mr. Van Patten directed that. Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. There was just the, yeah, it was a dream. By the way, I love that
所以，是的，他们联系了我们开个会，我当时吓坏了。才华横溢的范·帕滕导演了那部剧。我的天呐。对。对，对。简直就是，对，简直就像做梦一样。顺便说一句，我喜欢
their company is called Team Downey, which is always fun to me. I think that's a great company name. I've always been jealous of that, but I don't want Robert to know. I would have called it Touchdowny. Yeah. Oh, that's good. That's nice. That's fun. Yeah, it's fun. It's just like I'm looking to call,
他们的公司叫“唐尼团队”，这对我来说总是很有趣。我认为这是一个很棒的公司名字。我一直都很嫉妒，但我不想让罗伯特知道。我会把它叫作“触地得分唐尼”。对。噢，那挺好。挺不错的。挺有趣的。对，挺有趣的。就像我正打算把我的，
name mine, Master Bateman, but it will not, has not cleared. So Robert, so Team Downey reaches out and you go and you meet with these guys and you're like, you're like, did you know that it was going to become this group? Like what was your first thought of it when you, were you like excited? Were you sort of skeptical? Were you? I mean, I was, I was slightly skeptical because I have, like, did you develop it with them or was it a script? Well, you're also carrying a bunch of peddict.
我的命名为“巴特曼大师”，不过它不会，还没有通过审核。所以罗伯特，所以唐尼团队联系了你，你去和这几个人见了面，然后你就像，你就像，你知道它会变成这样一个团队吗？当你接触它时，你的第一想法是什么？你当时很兴奋吗？你有点怀疑吗？我是说，我，我有点怀疑，因为我，就像，你是和他们一起开发的还是看剧本？好吧，你还带着一大堆……
out of the Americans. You won the Emmy. The Americans and brothers and sisters that you did for five years with our old buddy Robbie Bates? My old friend. You did not want it to suck. No, no.
《美国谍梦》的包袱。你赢得了艾美奖。《美国谍梦》和你在我们老朋友罗比·贝茨手下干了五年的《兄弟姐妹》？我的老朋友。你可不想把它搞砸。不，不。
But that was never in doubt because, you know, I think when you saw Team Downey, you know, the writers on it, Tim Van Patten, HBO, it was kind of, it was straight to, I wasn't concerned that it wouldn't be of a certain caliber.
但那从来都不是问题，因为，你知道，我想当你看到唐尼团队、里面的编剧、蒂姆·范·帕滕、HBO，它就直接，我不担心它达不到某种水准。
If anything, like, you know, usually it stems from my own insecurity as well, know, how I can turn it into a catastrophe more than anything else. But I was very excited. I loved it. It was pitched as a one-off. And they were like, look, we just want to do the origin story and that'll be it. And then, you know, halfway through, they were like, you know, it works pretty good. It looks good. We should think about doing this, you know, we should think about doing more of this. I did have that small reservation where I've done, where I've kind of, you know, Perry Mason is still revered.
如果非要说的话，你知道，通常这也源于我自己的不安全感，你知道，比起别的，我更擅长如何把它变成一场灾难。但我非常兴奋。我很喜欢。它最初被当成一部限定剧来推介。他们当时说，听着，我们只想做起源故事，这就够了。然后，你知道，进行到一半时，他们说，你知道，效果挺不错。看起来挺好。我们应该考虑做这个，你知道，我们应该考虑拍更多。我当时确实有点保留意见，因为我做过，因为我有点，你知道，人们对《梅森探长》依然充满敬意。
Well, it was in the UK. It was huge. And here also, there is a certain generation of an age group up that kind of go, no, no, no, you can't touch Mason, but you know, you have to leave that alone. And then a ton of people have no recollection of the show whatsoever. And that's what Susan said. She said, look, there's an entire, there are swathes of generations ready for a new Perry Mason.
嗯，在英国是这样的。它非常轰动。在这里也是，有一代人和某个年龄段的人会觉得，不，不，不，你不能碰梅森，你知道，你得离它远点。然后有大量的人对这部剧完全没有记忆。苏珊就是这么说的。她说，听着，有整整一代又一代的人，已经准备好迎接一个新的《梅森探长》了。
Yeah, we can do it. We can make him whatever he want. And where did you guys shoot that? In L.A. They went back to the origin story in the books, which was 1930s L.A., which to me was, you know, with Chinatown and everything else, was such, was so alluring.
对，我们能做到。我们可以把他塑造得要什么样就什么样。你们是在哪里拍摄的？在洛杉矶。他们回到了书中的起源故事，也就是20世纪30年代的洛杉矶，对我来说，你知道，伴随着唐人街和其他种种，是如此，是如此迷人。
And as a kid growing up watching old movies, I was like, oh my God, I get to wear a fedora in L.A. And you do an American accent? Yeah, yeah. You get to wear a fedora in L.A. like everybody else in Venice, right? In air. Yeah, or Los Feles, yeah. As an actor, is the American accent a tough thing to do?
作为一个看着老电影长大的孩子，我当时想，天呐，我能在洛杉矶戴上一顶软呢帽了。你还得说美国口音？对，对。你能在洛杉矶戴软呢帽，就像威尼斯的每个人一样，对吧？在空气中。对，或者洛斯费利兹，对。作为一名演员，美国口音是一件很难掌握的事情吗？
And do you have like a phrase that clicks you right into the typical American sound that's sort of like a shortcut for you? No, there's not real short. It's still a huge, it's like a, I say block. Like hamburger. Well, I tell you what, well, yeah. I tell you what, killer. I went up to one of the writers early on in Perry Mason.
你有没有那种能让你立刻切换到典型美国发音的短语，对你来说就像是个捷径？不，没有真正的捷径。这依然是个巨大的，就像一个，我说“街区”。就像“汉堡包”。好吧，我跟你说，好吧，对。我跟你说，杀人犯。我在《梅森探长》早期曾找过其中一个编剧，
I said, hey, is there any chance we can change, like, murderer to killer? And he's like, you do realize you've signed on for Perry Mason? Like, you're going to be saying murderer a lot. And I was like, yeah, I hadn't quite thought that one, too. That's a bit of an Achilles heel for me. That's a tough word to say. Yeah, like your batteries run out halfway through. You just go, murderer.
我说，嘿，有没有可能我们把“谋杀犯”换成“凶手”之类的词？他当时说，你难道意识到你签的是《梅森探长》吗？听着，你会有很多机会说“谋杀犯”这个词的。我当时想，对，我之前没想到这一点。这对我来说算是个阿喀琉斯之踵。这是个很难发音的词。对，就像你的电池在一半的时候就耗尽了。你只能说，谋杀犯。
Murderer. Murder. I was like, can you say killer? What about suspect? Suspect would be great. Right, because the British accent would put an A-H on a murderer. Yeah. Murder.
谋杀犯。谋杀。我当时想，你能说“凶手”吗？“嫌疑人”怎么样？“嫌疑人”倒挺不错。对，因为英国口音会在“谋杀犯”后面加上一个“啊”的音。对。谋杀。
Murder. Yeah. Murder. By the way, if you're going to live in America, you've got to learn how to say murderer. I mean, sorry. I know. That's not true. Yeah.
谋杀。对。谋杀。顺便说一句，如果你打算在美国生活，你得学会怎么说“谋杀犯”。我是说，对不起。我知道。那不是真的。对。
It's going to be the thing you're going to say the most. Jesus Christ. Well, I mean, now, so now you've got the second season of, of Perry Mason coming out, which is fantastic, which you never thought you'd do. No. And that was delayed a bit, yeah?
这将成为你最常说的一个词。耶稣基督。好吧，我是说，现在，所以现在你们迎来了第二季的《梅森探长》，这太棒了，这是你从未想过会去做的。不。而且那延期了一段时间，对吧？
With COVID, perhaps? Hugely delayed, because it's too into a detriment moment, no, we're going to wait. We're not going to shrink the show and make a smaller show of the first one. We'll wait until we can make the same big show with hundreds of supporting artists and do it right. Right, because there's a lot of background players
也许是因为新冠？极大地延期了，因为这是个会带来损害的时刻，不，我们要等待。我们不会把这部剧缩水，把它拍得比第一季小。我们要等到能拍出同样宏大、拥有几百名群众演员的大制作，并且把它做好。对，因为有很多背景演员，
in a lot of crowd scenes. It's a massive production. Oh my, it's a beast. There are those days I turn up on set and I go, I don't even know how this works. My brother-in-law was a tank commander in the British Army for most of his life. And he said it's all,
还有很多群戏。这是一部庞大的制作。噢，天呐，简直是个庞然大物。有时候我出现在片场会想，我甚至不知道这怎么运转。我的连襟大半辈子都是英国陆军的坦克指挥官。他说这完全，
it's like if you think about the logistics, they have to do, it's insane. But he came on set one day and he went, how does this work? And he was just so shocked. He goes, what amazes me, he said, what amazes me is that so many components have to come together in one tiny moment
这就像如果你考虑到后勤保障，他们必须做到的那些，简直太疯狂了。但他有一天来到片场说，这怎么运转？他当时太震惊了。他说，让我震惊的是，他说，让我震惊的是，那么多复杂的元素必须在一个极其微小的时刻汇聚在一起，
and be quiet. he said it was it sort of staggered him he was like he was like amazed at the cold sheets and everything it is it's true when you watch when you go to a big film television set and you watch all these people who are at the top of their game
然后保持安静。他说这简直让他感到震惊，他当时就，他就像对那些冷色调的床单和一切都感到惊叹。确实如此，当你观看，当你去到一个大型电影电视片场，看着所有这些处于各自领域巅峰的人，
and they're seeing like you said come together in that moment where everybody's got to be silent and everything's got to be great and you see it pulled off sometimes it has the timing of something that has to happen in the shots whatever it is it is pretty amazing to watch how good these
然后他们就像你说的，汇聚在那个所有人都必须保持沉默、一切都必须完美的时刻，你看到它顺利完成了，有时它的节奏精确得就像必须在镜头前发生的某件事，无论是什么，看着这些人把他们的工作做得如此出色，
people are at what they do. Yeah. And filming in New York, which we obviously did the Americans. Oh, yeah. It's staggering that they get away with what they do in the kind of... Like, location department should be given flack jackets these days
真的是太棒了。对。而且在纽约拍摄，我们显然拍过《美国谍梦》。噢，对。他们在那种地方竟然能瞒过所有人，这太让人震惊了……像外景部门现在都该发防弹背心了，
for the amount of abuse they just get from people who want to park, drive down the street, or, you know, enter a shop. But how many times have you had that when you're shooting in New York on the street and then it's like pretty good and then like somewhere in the take,
因为他们总是遭到那些只想停车、开车穿过街道或者，你知道，进商店的人的各种辱骂。但你在纽约街头拍摄时，有多少次遇到这种情况：一开始还挺顺利，然后就在某个镜头进行到一半时，
you just hear somebody leaning out of window going, I want to be in the fucking... movies. All the time. All right. If it says exterior night in the Americans, you know you're looping it. You know you're ADRing it
你突然听到有人探出窗外喊道：“我想上他妈的……电影。”每次都这样。好吧。如果《美国谍梦》剧本上写着“外景-夜”，你就知道你得后期配音了。你知道你得做台词替换（ADR），
because you know there's someone shouting along the line. There was this one time in Harlem. I was doing a scene. And it was like eight guys because I had to shout the scene. Eight guys were shouting the exact same words along with me. Because they've heard it so many times.
因为你知道路上总会有人在大喊大叫。有一次在哈林区。我在拍一场戏。当时大约有八个人，因为我得大声喊出台词，那八个人竟然在旁边跟我一起大喊着完全相同的台词。因为他们听了太多遍了。
Yeah. Matthew, we have taken up so much of your time. My God, I just really, we can talk to you for every. You're a real treat. You're one of us. You're one of us. God, you're one of us. This has been a real treat. Shaw, I can't wait to see the show. We're all coming to see it. We're very excited about it. Oh, that's so nice. Thank you. How our preview's going? Really well, really exhausting. But thank you for asking. I walked down the street one day,
对。马修，我们占用了你这么长时间。天呐，我真的，我们可以跟你聊个没完。你真是个大好人。你是我们的一员。你是我们的一员。天呐，你是我们的一员。这真是一次极好的体验。肖恩，我迫不及待想看这部剧了。我们都要去看。我们对此非常兴奋。噢，太好了。谢谢。我们的超前点映怎么样？非常好，也非常累人。但谢谢你问。我有一天走在街上，
today, walked down the street to go get my little sandwich, my egg sandwich. On a Kaiser roll. And this woman, this woman stopped me. She was really sweet, but this is how much energy was in her voice. She grabbed my eyes. She goes, I saw your show last night. I go, yeah? Thank you for coming. She goes, it was really good. And she just kept walking. I love New York.
今天，走在街上去买我的小三明治，我的鸡蛋三明治。夹在凯撒圆面包里的。然后这个女人，这个女人拦住了我。她人真的很好，但她说话时的语气充满了能量。她抓住我的眼睛。她说：“我昨晚看了你的剧。”我说：“是吗？谢谢你能来看。”她说：“真的很好看。”然后她就径直走开了。我爱纽约。
New York undefeated. And that's it. I was like, last time I did a play, I was, I was walking from the theater. And this woman just shouted, you're an asshole. And I just went, I hope you saw the show. That's not personal. Matthew, well, when we come to New York, I hope that we can grab a meal. you, me and Kerry, and maybe one of these
纽约永远不败。就是这样。我想起上次我演话剧时，我正从剧院走出来。然后这个女人突然大喊：“你是个混蛋。”我当时就回了句：“希望你看过这部剧。”这不是针对个人。马修，等我们去纽约时，我希望我们能一起吃顿饭，你、我和凯瑞，可能还有这几个
ding-dongs as well. Let's go. Yes, please. Get Sean and Scotty and J.B. and we'll do it up. It'll be great to see you, man. Thank you for having me. This has been such a treat.
傻瓜一起。走吧。好的，拜托。叫上肖恩、斯科蒂和JB，我们大吃一顿。见到你太棒了，老兄。谢谢你邀请我。这真是一次美妙的体验。
Thank you, Matthew. And send all of our love to Carrie. We will. We adore her as well. And we adore you. You are, as Sean said. You're one of us. It's been such a pleasure, buddy.
谢谢你，马修。代我们向凯瑞问好。我们会转达的。我们也同样崇拜她。我们也崇拜你。正如肖恩所说。你就是我们的一员。能和你聊天太高兴了，兄弟。
And a continued success. Perry Mason comes out. What's the release? It's out now. It's out now. Monday nights at 9. Yeah. Monday nights at 9.
祝你事事顺利。《梅森探长》上映了。什么时候上映？现在已经播出了。现在就播出了。每周一晚9点。对。每周一晚9点。
There we go. HBO, Max. Yeah. Congratulations. So, thank you. Yeah, congratulations all the success, buddy. Thank you guys. Thanks, amen.
就是这样。HBO，Max。对。恭喜。所以，谢谢。对，祝你一切顺利，兄弟。谢谢你们。谢谢，兄弟。
Thanks for being here, buddy. Have a good day. Bye, bye, bye-bye. And you slam it shut. Now, there's a nice guy. Well, what's a nice guy like that being, how is he friends with you? Because that's the kind of,
谢谢你能来，兄弟。祝你有美好的一天。再见，再见，再见。然后你“啪”地把门关上。瞧，这真是个好人。好吧，像这样的大好人怎么会，他是怎么跟你成为朋友的？因为那是那种，
that's the ilk of people that I attract. You know what I mean? It's just like-minded people. Birds of a feather. Cool dudes. He's charming. He knows that to carry on a conversation. Yeah, I know.
那是我吸引的人的类型。你知道我的意思吗？都是志同道合的人。物以类聚。酷小伙。他很有魅力。他知道如何维持对话。对，我知道。
I'm always impressed with guys like that who were just so, like, relaxed, like that late. Like, well, he's confident, you know. He's comfortable, you know, he's got his uniform, he has his black t-shirt and his- He's not like you guys, he doesn't have an ax to grind, you know what I mean? He doesn't have something to prove all the time.
我总是对那些如此随性、总是那么放松的家伙印象深刻。就像，嗯，他很自信，你知道。他很自在，你知道，他有他的制服，他穿着黑色T恤和他的——他不像你们这些家伙，他没有什么满腹牢骚，你知道我的意思吗？他不用时时刻刻证明自己。
He's not trying to prove anything with his fun tops that he wears, Sean. I'm a fun top. Now, listen. I know you want. Speaking of which, where's the cocaine bear? What's he fixing now? Huh? He's fixing something.
他可不是在用他穿的那些花哨上衣来证明什么，肖恩。我就是穿花哨上衣的。现在，听着。我知道你想要什么。说到这个，那个“可卡因熊”去哪了？他现在在弄什么？啊？他在弄点东西。
Scotty, what are you making? What kind of sandwich? Oh, you had a Turks. He had a Turk sandwich. Oh, a Turk sandwich? Wait, what else is on it? What goes on a Turk sandwich of the day? Hang on, what percentage of the day when you yell out,
斯科蒂，你在做什么？什么三明治？噢，你吃了一个土耳其三明治。噢，土耳其三明治？等等，里面还有什么？一天的土耳其三明治里都有什么料？等等，当你在大喊大叫时，一天里有百分之几的几率，
hey, Scotty, what are you doing? Is the answer, I'm making a sandwich? Well, usually it's for me. Making Sammies. That's what I mean? Well, so what do we got on the turkey? How do you like your turkey sandwich done, Sean? I ordered one, I had one yesterday for lunch.
嘿，斯科蒂，你在干嘛？得到的回答是：我在做三明治？好吧，通常那是为我自己做的。做三明治。这就是我的意思？好吧，那火鸡肉里都有什么？肖恩，你喜欢你的火鸡三明治怎么做？我点过一个，我昨天午餐吃了一个。
It was a turkey, avocado, lettuce, and extra, extra, extra, extra mayo. Oh, and are we toasting the bread? No. Really? How about a light toast? with a little snap on it. It's like a real soft thing there. Extra, do you literally say extra, extra, extra, extra mail?
里面有火鸡肉、牛油果、生菜，还有超、超、超、超多蛋黄酱。噢，我们要烤面包吗？不。真的吗？稍微烤一下怎么样？带一点脆感。就像那种真正的软面包。超，你真的是说超、超、超、超多蛋黄酱吗？
Yes, I always do, because they never put enough on. You know what I like? I like it when you get one of those, like a sort of like an Italian, you know what I mean? With different cuts of meat, some cold cuts, lettuce, tomato and get some... Drop it into the Brooklyn eggs. Some oil and vinegar and get a little salt peps. You know, by the way, it reminds me I was saying about the wearing the hats all around. I remember, remember Thoreau went through a long phase.
对，我总是这么说，因为他们从来不肯放够。你知道我喜欢什么吗？我喜欢你拿到那种，就像某种意大利式的三明治，你知道我的意思吗？有不同的切片肉，一些冷盘肉，生菜，西红柿，再加点……把它浸入布鲁克林鸡蛋里。加点油和醋，再撒一点盐和胡椒。你知道，顺便说一句，这让我想起刚才说的到处戴帽子的事。我记得，记得梭罗经历过很长一段时间，
He was always wearing, like, hats and little pork pie hats and fedoras and stuff. And I remember Polar said to one day, you look fedorable and just really killed us. Hey, what kind of hat do I have on today? You got one of those smartless merch hats. That's right. Yeah. Where do we get one of those?
他总是戴着，比如，各种帽子、小圆顶礼帽和软呢帽之类的东西。我记得波拉有一天对某人说，你看起来“太适于戴帽了”（fedorable），真的把我们笑死了。嘿，我今天戴的是什么帽子？你戴着那种“聪明无赖”的周边帽子。没错。对。我们在哪能买到那种？
Sorry to interrupt, guys. It looks like Carrie Russell's entering the waiting room. She might just want to say hi. You want to just pop up. Put her on. Put a carry on. Then we're going to air it. There she is.
抱歉打扰你们了，伙计们。看起来凯瑞·拉塞尔进候诊室了。她可能只是想打个招呼。你想让她连线进来吗。接通她。把凯瑞接进来。然后我们要播出了。她来了。
If you can hear us, hello. We'll have to have her on. I will tell the boys they can't hear you. right now because they're on the other system. You were fantastic. Thank you. Bye. Okay, thanks for everything.
如果你能听到我们说话，你好。我们得请她上节目。我要告诉这几个男孩他们听不到你说话，因为他们现在用的是另一套系统。你刚才太棒了。谢谢。再见。好的，谢谢你做的一切。
Really appreciate it. Well done. I love that we just had a quick visual visit from Kerry, Russell. We couldn't hear her, but we got to see her and she was there. She was probably with the kids, right, Sean? Yeah, she probably would. It's about time for pickup. Yeah, it's probably for nap time for our kids, which she would then sing.
真的很感激。干得好。我喜欢我们刚才和凯瑞·拉塞尔进行了一次快速的视频连线。我们听不见她说话，但我们看到了她，她就在那里。她可能跟孩子们在一起，对吧，肖恩？对，她可能在。差不多是接孩子放学的时间了。对，大概是我们孩子们的午睡时间，她那时会给他们唱歌。
What would she sing to them if she was going to put her kids to bed? She would probably sing like. Rock of... Bye! Maybe. Jason hates when we go up. He just pinches that voice off. Bye.
如果她要哄孩子们睡觉，她会给他们唱什么歌？她可能会唱类似……《摇篮曲》……再见！也许吧。杰森最讨厌我们搞这种突然袭击。他直接把那个声音掐断了。再见。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbago. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《聪明无赖》（SmartLess）由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆贾夫和本尼特·巴尔巴戈100%有机手工制作。聪明无赖。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。